Die
Auf gehts Oh, der Stream laggt
Warum laggt der Stream?
Vodafone, was ist da los?
Stats?
Drop Frames?
Nö, es laggt überhaupt nix, keck wait Alles gut
Ach, der Raspberry Pi hat zwei Kerne, aber trotzdem deutlich langsamer als ein ESP32,
oder?
Der ESP32, es hat irgendwie Dual-Core 240MHz, sonst was, und der Pico hat doch irgendwie
80 oder so?
Gut, ich meine, direkt Herz-Takt-Frequenz kannst du nicht direkt miteinander vergleichen,
aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, das ist eine ganze Ecke
Ah, ja, Mikrophone ist zu laut, das kann sein, weil Teams wieder dran rumgestellt hat
Ja, viel zu laut gewesen, MonkaS Tribbolo, danke für den Zapp
Ah, ja, mal Update machen jetzt, ups, ja ja, Update machen
Ja, mal gucken, wie weit wir kommen
Ja, deswegen verstehe ich immer noch nicht den Sinn davon, warum man den Raspberry Pi
so verwendet, außer vielleicht wirklich die Baugröße, oder weil er Raspberry Pi im Namen
hat vielleicht, keine Ahnung, weiß es nicht
Trust, alles klar, wir trusten hier, mit alles und jedem wird getrusted, also vertraut nicht
trusted, nicht trusted, ja, so, erstmal updaten hier
GH1 und GH2 nächste Woche, ach, das schaffst du easy, weil solange du ein paar Prüfungen
im Vorfeld gemacht hast, ist das überhaupt kein Problem, man muss sich einfach an die
Frage, Art der IHK gewöhnen, danach ist das alles, wie geht's dir heute, ok, von eins
bis zehn, erstmal überlegen, bin schon noch zwei Stunden draußen rumgelaufen, ich hab
vorhin was gefressen und ich mach jetzt Stream, also ich würd sagen, also 10 vor 10 ist zu
übertrieben, sag mal 8 vor 10, aber 8 vor 10, geht ja immer besser
ja gut, BWL, BWL ist eh Payne's Champ, ganz ehrlich, selbst wenn du nur eine 4 in BWL
hast, Hauptsache du hast den Krempel bestanden, ich hatte auch keine allzu gute Abschlussprüfung,
ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, was ich, also schriftliche, schriftliche meine schriftliche
Abschlussprüfung war auch nicht allzu geil, dafür hatte ich 95% bei der mündlichen, wahrscheinlich
wollten sie mir aus Prinzip keine 100 geben, keine Ahnung, schriftliche war glaube ich
nicht so grandios, aber die IHK Prüfung ist eh an randomness kaum zu überbieten für
eine Prüfung, die Fragen sind für den Arsch, du weißt teilweise nicht, was sie wollen
und wenn du es weißt, dann denkst du dir, so muss ich es jetzt wirklich ganz korrekt
beantworten, oder so korrekt, dass es die IHK akzeptiert, oder man weiß es nicht.
Also Leute, ich zeige euch mal kurz, was ich also am Start habe, ich habe mir eine Wetterstation
gekauft und zwar baugleich ist das ganze Ding mit einer Fein Offset WH 2900, deswegen zeige
ich euch einfach nur die, die gibt es in zig Reseller, Reseller? Reseller? Reseller heißt
glaube ich, von zig Resellern gibt es die, diese Wetterstation. So, das Ding habe ich
mir gekauft, so um die 130 Euro bei Amazon, wie das die coolen Leute jetzt sagen würden
und die Wetterstation selbst steht draußen mit der Wetterstation direkt, kann man nicht
allzu viel machen, die macht nichts außer Wetter empfangen, die ist relativ langweilig,
was ganz spannend ist, ist diese Empfänger hier. Die Wetterstationen der Empfänger kommunizieren
über Funk, das machen wir in einem der nächsten Streams, da werde ich mal gucken, ob man das
Funkzeug direkt abgreifen kann, dafür habe ich mir auch schon den passenden Stick und
die passenden Antennen bestellt, aber heute gucken wir mal, ob wir irgendwie diese Stationen
halbwegs ordentlich auslesen können, wobei ich viel eher gar nicht so auslesen, auslesen
ist, gibt es fertige Sachen für, dass das funktioniert, aber, dass die Stationen gescheit
funktioniert ist ohne Internetanbindung nicht so einfach, warum wird das Bild jetzt auf
einmal größer, ich habe nichts geklickt, ah, weil China-Chinesen Seitenverhältnis,
die Stationen zu betreiben wird relativ schwierig, weil in bester China-Chinesen Tradition möchte
diese Station natürlich Internetzugang haben, deswegen müssen wir heute mal gucken, ob wir
es irgendwie gefaked bekommen, dass die Station auch der Meinung ist zu funktionieren und
sich auch Uhrzeiten zu holen und sowas, wenn wir nur so tun, als ob, mal schauen, ich zeige
euch, ich zeige euch das Ding mal kurz, also, mein sehr aufgeräumter Schreibtisch, also
das Schreibtisch, mein sehr aufgeräumter Basteltisch hier am Start, ja, also hier ist
der Access Point, den kennt ihr ja schon, Schmoll, Schmoll Mini Access Point, den brauchen wir
da heute dafür, das ist so ganz billiger, 15, 20 Euro Mikro Tick, 2,4 GHz Only Access
Point, aber für so Testsachen ist der richtig gut, ein vollwertiges Router OS, ihr werdet
gleich sehen, was für Proc Sachen man damit machen kann, oder ich gehe mal davon aus,
man braucht das, so, und das hier ist diese Wetterstation, beziehungsweise das Display,
was, oh, Spiegelung, MonkaS, Huge, Huge Spiegelung, hier ist, das ist die Wetter, was die Funkdaten
von der eigentlichen Außenunit empfängt, so, und ich mach das jetzt mal an, achso,
ich zeige euch vielleicht erstmal das Kabel, was ich gebaut habe, passt mal auf, ähm,
ich bin das Netzteil grad gar nicht, ist egal, zumindest diese Station, die läuft
mit 5 Volt, und ich dachte mir, so USB ist doch auch 5 Volt, und mir ist es lieber, ich
betreib das über USB, also auf dem Netzteil stand 5 Volt, 1 Ampere, also das kriegste
mit USB zur Not auch noch hin, und da hab ich folgendes gemacht, jetzt werdet ihr euch
gleich kecken, wenn ich euch das zeige, jetzt werdet ihr gleich kecken, guckt mal hier,
da ist der, da ist der Anschluss, und jetzt, Bam, ich hab einfach nur das Bestecker dran
gemacht, easy, und es funktioniert, also ich hab einfach die Kabel in so zwei Lötverbinder
gesteckt, mit dem Feuerzeug heiß gemacht, verklebt, geschrumpft, schlaucht und auch
ein bisschen, äh, Silikonband drüber und gut ist, so, und jetzt kann ich das hier einstecken,
guckt mal, kann ich das hier einstecken, und dann nehm ich den Stecker, steckt den hier
rein, und dann macht's Piep, und dann geht es an, guckt mal, dann geht es an, so, so
nur überlegen, wie man das am besten aufstellen, dass ihr was seht, Pork, also es funzt, so,
ähm, ich glaube, ich mach mal kurz den unten ab, weil man kann das hier hinten so, so hinstellen,
guckt mal, da ist ein QR-Code, chat, scan mal einer den QR-Code, wo kommt man da raus,
ich hol mal kurz mein iPad für den QR-Code, Spiegeleak, oh nein, oder, wo kommt man da
raus, hinten, ich, ich guck mal, ich hol mal kurz mein, mein iPad,
ich, ich scanne das mal kurz, mal gucken, was das für ein QR-Code ist, wo man da raus
kommt, ähm, Kamera, auf, da, da kommt man bei irgendeiner ID raus, keine Ahnung, da
wahrscheinlich ist da die MAC-Adresse oder so encoded, das werden wir eh alles leaken
heute, also insofern wurscht, aber vielleicht kann man es jetzt so hinstellen, dass man
das sieht, ja, guck mal, ihr erkennt das doch so eigentlich ganz gut, so, sieht doch, sieht
doch eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus, ich mein, ein bisschen, ein bisschen mehr gekippt müssten
wir uns vielleicht, oh guck mal, jetzt MAX steht da drauf, so, also, Problem ist, wie
ihr vielleicht festgestellt habt, das Ding möchte ins Internet, dass zum Beispiel hier
oben die Zeit automatisch gesetzt wird und das Datum automatisch abgerufen wird und Wettervorhersage
automatisch angezeigt wird, gut, die Daten von der Sensor, von dem Außensensor funktionieren,
das ist kein Problem, ne, im liegt man KS und dementsprechend ist das halt ein bisschen
doof, deswegen müssen wir gucken, dass wir heute den Traffic mitschneiden von dieser
Station, was das so macht, ähm, dann gucken, ob wir das irgendwie gefaked kriegen, was
die Station haben möchte, sodass automatisches Zeitsetzen und so funktioniert, also ich vermute
mal, es gibt zwei Sachen, die man machen muss, oder vielleicht, wenn wir Glück haben, nur
eine Sache, ich hoffe, die benutzen NTP, das heißt, wir müssen einen NTP-Server hier auf
dem Access-Point einrichten und vielleicht reicht das schon, wenn wir bei DHCP dem Ding
mitteilen, benutzt den NTP-Server, vielleicht geht's dann schon, aber so wie ich China-Chinesen-Zeug
kenne, wahrscheinlich nicht, weiss ich, Chat, was meint ihr, benutzt das Ding NTP, also,
was ich mir vorstellen kann, das Ding benutzt NTP, nämlich den NTP, den man eben vom DHCP-Server
gibt, das wäre die schöne Variante, das wäre easy, oder das Ding benutzt gar kein NTP,
sondern macht Web-Requests an China-Chinesen-Web-Server und wenn die nicht mit der richtigen Antwort
zurückkommen, dann geht nichts, was haltet ihr für wahrscheinlicher, richtig schön über
NTP oder China-Chinesen-Web-Request, wenn wir Pech haben, wenn wir Pech haben beides,
ich tippe aber auch auf China-Web-Request, wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil das Ding hat, die
linke Seite funktioniert fast gar nicht ohne Internetanschluss, rechts sind die Sensordaten
von der Station, ist alles okay, aber der ganze Krempel hier, also eigentlich der obere
Teil hier, der funktioniert halt nicht ohne Internetanschluss, sobald ich Internetanschluss
freigebe, kein Ding funktioniert alles, so, das kann auch sein, dass es beides ist, ich
weiß es nicht, vielleicht machen die auch NTP an irgendeinen China-Chinesen-Server
bei AliExpress, man weiß es ja nicht, man weiß es ja nicht, das heißt, ich hab, das
einzige was ich jetzt schon gemacht hab, chat, ist folgendes, es gibt eine App, die kann
ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil die App hab ich auf meinem Smartphone und das Smartphone
ist da, hier, da, da wo ihr seid, ist das Smartphone, das nimmt grad auf, also, da gibt
es nämlich eine App dafür, aber wie weiß das Ding die Timezone, ähm, das ist ne gute
Frage, vielleicht kann man die Timezone am Gerät setzen, Timezone über NTP geht nicht,
oder? Ach, keine Ahnung, wir werden es gleich sehen, das Ding hat keine GPS Zeit, nö, die
Chinesen sparen, wo man nur sparen kann und ein GPS-Empfänger war da nicht drin, ist auch
gut, dass kein GPS-Empfänger drin ist, chat, wenn da ein GPS-Empfänger drin gewesen wär,
dann würd ich jetzt das Video nicht machen, ich will nicht, ich will nicht das Risiko
eingehen, dass ich meine GPS-Koordinaten leake, so, also, es gibt eine App auf dem
Channel, du hast ja nichts verpasst, es gibt eine App für Smartphone, nennt sich WS, WS-View-App,
ja meinetwegen, wie riecht da, was, oh, ah, Firefox, ok, perfekt, also, es gibt eine App,
die sich WS-View nennt, ich kann die euch nicht zeigen, weil wie gesagt, die App ist
hier auf dem Smartphone, das funktioniert nicht, die sieht so aus, das ist eine mega hässliche
App, aber, man braucht die App gar nicht, man braucht die App nur, um initial die Station
mit dem WLAN zu verbinden, hab ich gemacht, und zwar in das WLAN von diesem Access-Point
hier, das ist nur ein Test-WLAN-Access-Point und das Ding darf auch nirgendwo hin, das
kriegt einfach bei DHCP in das Server, also WS-View von Wipeng, und so sieht die App aus,
man sieht das leider nicht, den Settings-Bildschirm, zumindest kann man im Settings-Bildschirm
einstellen, dass man die Daten von diesem Ding an den Server schicken kann, bei sich
lokal, das ist eigentlich ganz nice, das werde ich dann auch später machen, aber mir geht's
jetzt hauptsächlich erstmal darum, dass wir ein bisschen mitschneiden, was diese Wetterstation
hier macht, bzw. was die hier mit dem Internet kommunizieren will, und vielleicht kriegen
wir das dann irgendwie nachgebaut, mal gucken, also wie gesagt, die Wetterstation ist dieses
Teil hier gerade, das hier ist draußen auf der Garage, und das Ding steht da, so, und
das hier ist der Access-Point, über den wir gerade drin sind, da unten der, und das hier
ist das Config-Interface vom Access-Point, das ist ein ganz billiger Mikrotik-Lite, AC,
das kostet nicht viel, nee, AC, AP, hier, boah, es ist teuer geworden, Alter, das hat
mal 15, 20 Euro gekostet, sogar kleine Access-Points werden teuer als fuck, Mikrotik-Map-Lite, krass,
nicht, nicht WAP, Map, auch LTE, LITE, was macht denn Google da wieder draus, boah, ist
das teuer geworden, man, ja, das hier waren eher mal die Ursprungspreise, das ist richtig
teuer geworden, man kann auch bei Equipa kaufen, ja, so in dem Dreh, zumindest, das ist ein
ganz billiger Access-Point hier, der kann auch nur 2,4 Gigahertz, und das Gute an dem
ist, dass er vollwertiges Router-OS drauf hat, das heißt, man kann hier mit ganz abgedrehten
Geschichten machen, obwohl es, also es ist zum Rumspielen für solche Sachen der beste
Access-Point für unter 30 Euro, weil man ebenso viel mitmachen kann, Puzzle-Meister,
danke für den Zapp, nochmal auf den Chat einzugehen, ich hab mich ein paar Sachen
überlesen, gut, dass ich das hier nochmal auf hab, ähm, kennst du einen, nee, kenn
ich nicht, Ebolon, danke für den Zapp, hat er nicht eben noch, war jemand was geschrieben,
was ich übersehen hab, nee, anscheinend nicht, gut, ja, es ist alles mega teuer geworden,
so, und was ich mir jetzt überlegt hab, ist folgendes, wir gehen jetzt auf den Access-Point
und schneiden einfach mal den Traffic mit, den diese Station da macht, und dann gucken
wir uns, Chainlord, mein Firefox hat Probleme mit deinem Namen, hab ich keine China-Chinesen-Japanische
Zeichensätze installiert, kann das sein, Linux, Pont, ja, ja, was muss ich denn dafür installieren,
alles klar, die da, das da brauchen wir wahrscheinlich, ja, so, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob der Chainlord
gleich richtig dargestellt wird, wenn wir das hier so machen, da muss ich aber Firefox
für neu starten, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, weil dann geht mein Kamerafenster wieder zu,
wir installieren jetzt quasi, achja, Ja-Schrift an, ok Chainlord, lass es nochmal ausprobieren,
oh, der Chat ist kaputt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kann es nochmal ausprobieren, hey, funktioniert,
sehr schön, so muss das sein, gut, ich würde sagen, also mein Ziel ist heute folgendes,
ich möchte, dass diese Wetterstation, also hier, was ihr hier seht, ich will, dass die
beim Neustart sich verbindet, Wetter, also Wettervorhersage, mal gucken, aber dass zumindest
automatisch die Uhrzeit mal gesetzt wird und dass ich einfach weiß, was das Ding, wenn
ich es ans Internet hängen würde, denn macht, ich hänge es nicht ans Internet, ausgeschlossen,
das Ding kommt definitiv nicht ans Internet, so viel, so viel ist klar, übrigens heute
kommt irgendwann noch Hermes, Leute, und bringt mir den Access Point, also die, die ich euch
gezeigt hab da letztens, ich hab auf Ebay super günstig einen gefunden, zwar vorvorletzte
Generation, aber hat nur 65 Euro gekostet, da hab ich einfach gesagt, komm, gib her,
zum ausprobieren reicht das, da kann ich jetzt mal gucken, wenn es ein gutes Angebot von
einer neueren Generation gibt und dann ist gut, ja, so, also, probieren wir das mal aus,
ich zeige euch jetzt mal ein bisschen das Config-Interface von dem Access Point, wohl
gemerkt, das ist nicht wirklich das Config-Interface rein von diesem Access Point hier, das ist
das Config-Interface von allen Mikrotik-Router an Access Point-Geräten, also von allen Mikrotik-Geräten
mit Router-OS drauf, also wenn ihr irgendein Gerät kauft von Mikrotik, was nicht CSS im
Namen hat, dann ist wahrscheinlich dieses Betriebssystem und dieses Web-Interface hier
drauf, in dem Fall ist es noch nicht mal ein Web-Interface, in dem Fall ist es ein lokaler
Client, aber das gleiche gibt es auch als Web-Interface, so, und was wir jetzt machen
ist, wir machen jetzt einmal den Strom raus und dann schmeißen wir irgendeinen Packet-Sniffer
an, dazu gibt es zwei, achso, ich zeige euch erstmal die Settings vom Access Point, also
hier kannst du Wireless-Sachen einstellen, relativ langweilig, WPA, du hast hier die
komplette Möglichkeit alles was du willst einzustellen von Firewall-Regeln bis DHCP-Server bis DNS-Geschichten
bis IPSEC, Samba-Freigarm, TFTP, also du kannst alles mögliche mitmachen, also Mikrotik, Router-OS
kann wirklich saumäßig viel, es ist im Prinzip auch nur in Linux drunter, aber ganz ehrlich,
das ist auf den meisten Sachen, auf den Unify-Geräten ist auch in Linux drunter und es ist halt
sehr nice, weil man so viel mit einstellen kann und über das Web-Interface, so, und
wie gesagt, du kannst WLANs einstellen, du kannst VPNs aufbauen, du hast zig Varianten
und du hast auch ein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool um das zu steuern, aber was halt sehr nice
ist, achso, DHCP-Server kann mich die Leases anzeigen lassen, das hier ist übrigens die
Wetterstation, wie ihr gerade seht, das ist die Wetterstation, also das ist die MAC,
das ist die IP von dem Ding, wir geben dem Ding mal eine Static-IP, weil, also so mache
ich das zumindest bei mir im normalen Router immer, und sagt dann irgendwie hier Wetter-Konsole,
so, da weiß man nämlich was es ist, gut, und jetzt haben wir eine statische IP für
das Ding reingehauen, das heißt wir können jetzt auch immer wieder die IP verwenden und
das ändert sich nicht, gut, man kann alles mögliche einstellen, also Router-OS ist komplett
Wissenschaft für sich, was ist das, achso, offene Fenster, aber es ist halt nice was
man mitmachen kann, so, und es gibt, wenn man Pakete mitschneiden will, Hausnahme startet
mit ESP, wieso, da ist ein ESP drinne, höchstwahrscheinlich ist da ein ESP drinne, wahrscheinlich sogar
ganz, ganz low-end ESP-6866, wundert mich nicht, das ist ein China-Chinesen-Gerät,
da sind gerne ESPs drinne, so, und wenn wir jetzt den Traffic mitschneiden wollen, gibt
es zwei Varianten, was man machen kann, es gibt einmal einen Packet-Sniffer, sieht dann
so aus, und es gibt eine, warum auch immer das Torch heißt, ich weiß nicht, es gibt
ein Programm, das heißt Torch, das hier ist ein Packet-Sniffer, der direkt im Web-Interface,
ich nenne das Ding jetzt mal Web-Interface, das ist zwar ein eigenes Problem, ich nenne
es mal Web-Interface, das hier ist ein Packet-Sniffer, der direkt im Web-Interface eingebaut ist,
und das hier ist ein Packet-Sniffer, der Sachen in der Datei schreiben kann, die ich am Ende
dann mit Wireshark aufmachen kann, also ich würde sagen, wir benutzen mal, man kann sich
aber hier trotzdem ein bisschen die Packages angucken, der hier ist halt ein bisschen schöner,
wenn man einfach nur im Web-Interface gucken will, aber wir zeichnen das mal auf, damit
wir mit Wireshark den Kram aufmachen können dann, so, also Filter, sagen wir Filter auf
Interfaces, WLAN, wir wollen nur WLAN-Traffic haben, weil das Ding hängt halt im WLAN,
und IP filtern wir auch mal, weil ansonsten, wobei, eigentlich so viel können wir nicht
kriegen, aber wir filtern sie trotzdem mal, 1 und 2, 1, 6, 8, 88, 2, 5, 1, so, Apply,
jetzt haben wir den Filter eingerichtet, jetzt können wir noch einstellen, Filename, nennen
wir mal kegw.pcup, pcup sind die Files, die Wireshark öffnen kann, wobei das ja nur eine
Name ist jetzt hier, das Format stimmt ja auch so schon, so, Apply, ok, und wenn wir jetzt
starten, dann schneidet das Ding alle Packages mit, die man so mitschneiden möchte, und
wenn man Glück haben tauchen die hier dann auch auf, aktuell ist die Kiste aus, deswegen
kommt noch nichts rein, wir machen die jetzt mal an, und dann schauen wir mal was passiert,
aha, guck mal, der macht schon Dinger, der macht schon Dinger, also, also wir können
uns das jetzt hier angucken, aber wir können uns danach im Wireshark angucken, im Wireshark
ist das besser zu sehen, also was macht der denn für Dinger, der macht erstmal 88,1,
das ist der Gateway, der macht DHCP, wir schneiden das mal, Leute, wir gucken uns das nicht hier
an, wir warten, wir warten, Google DNS, Moment, Google DNS, haben die Chinesen den Google
DNS Hardcoded oder was, ach Moment, Moment, was verteile ich denn per DHCP, Sekunde, Sekunde,
Leute, was, ach nee, ok, jetzt bin ich, ich verteile den Google DNS per DHCP, ok, anscheinend
greift der DNS schon mal aus DHCP, das ist gut zu wissen, das ist gut zu wissen, schön,
schauen wir noch mal kurz, ob wir NTP Server und so gleich mitgeben können, das müssen
wir ausprobieren, vielleicht können wir NTP Server mitgeben, so, aber wir lassen den
mal ganz kurz laufen und dann gucken wir mal in Wireshark rein, was der, was der macht,
wir lassen den mal kurz eine halbe Minute oder so laufen und dann gucken wir mal, was
ist das für eine Mode, Alter, was ist die Mode, das ist geil, das muss ich schreiben,
das ist so bescheuert, das mache ich rein, Moment, add to channel, auf geht's, ich kann
nix adden, Leute, ich kann nix adden, warum nicht, habe ich zu viele Emotes, wait a minute,
dashboard, ich habe 100 von 100 Emotes, Alter, 3 Milliarden Emotes, was ist denn da drin,
okay, chat, ich mache mal ein paar raus, pepolex verwendet niemand, ich habe noch nicht einmal
gesehen, dass irgendjemand hier in diesem Chat pepolex verwendet hat, remove und jetzt
machen wir das da rein, jetzt ist es zu spät, last spam, ich habe es rausgemacht, channel,
ich habe 7 TV nicht aktiviert, oh Mann, Alter, es wird ja immer schlimmer, ach du Scheiße,
ich will 7 TV nicht, das letzte Mal als ich mich darüber informiert habe, was 7 TV angeht,
da gab's höchst fragwürdige Emotes, da gab's zum Beispiel Adolf Hitler Emotes und ich bin
mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob ich eine Content Platform unterstützen will, die komplett ungefiltert
ist besser geworden, na vielleicht gucke ich es mir nochmal an, dass die komplett ungefiltert
irgendwelche Emotes einfach durchwinkt, das hat mich schon ein bisschen abgeschreckt.
der anderen seite hast du dann halt bei betta twitch tv und ffz gleich so extreme sachen
wie pochamp alle pochamp emotes removed und sowas oder alle alle äh äh wie hieß das
zulul emotes ja gut chainlord das heißt vielleicht nicht so das emote aber ich habs gesehen dass
es das gibt das fand ich nicht so toll aber weiter jetzt muss ich die aufnahme nicht die
aufnahme ich muss mal stoppen hier wir haben jetzt ganz schön lange aufgenommen also gucken wir
uns mal den mitschnitt an im fire im wireshark habe ich wireshark drauf ich habe kein wireshark
drauf weird champ cringe wer kein wireshark installiert hat und ich muss mal kurz meine
tastatur raus und wieder rein machen ich weiß nicht was die für schmerzen hat aber die leuchtet
rgb mäßig anstatt blau wie sie leuchten soll ah jetzt läuft so blau ok kein wireshark weird
champ richtig wird schimpf was aber wireshark drauf so wenn man jetzt diese mitschnitte hier
runter bekommen will geht man hier einfach auf files wohlgemerkt wir reden hier von einem 20
euro access point also ihr bekommt nirgends woanders ich müsste ich müsste geld vom mikrotik dafür
haben ihr bekommt nirgends woanders so viele funktionen zum rumbasteln wie bei dem 20 euro
mikrotik ok ihr könnt vielleicht open wrt auf was altes flaschen aber da habt ihr dann auch nicht
so viele sachen in dem schönen gui zumindest nicht das alles ich mein wer wollte nicht schon
immer mal mpls tunnel mit einem 20 euro mikrotik router access point machen map light mikrotik
map light 20 25 euro so keck wp cup download nach desktop das ist übrigens eine wine anwendung
hier deswegen ist das ein bisschen painstrap download so und jetzt müssen wir nach nach wine
ne wo liegt denn das wo liegt ein wine wo hat ein wine seine dateien liegen ach da ist es doch
lul winbox wine drive c users max desktop pick up das sind wir wire shark
wire schnee aufwarnen wire shark keck wp cup auf geht's ich switch das mal kurz dass man es
besser sieht dass hier oben das bild nicht in weg weg kommt also wire shark kann man es ein bisschen
größer machen ihr seht es nicht gut oder man kann es glaube ich nicht gut erkennen ich versuchte
mal ein bisschen größer zu machen da ich habe noch nie in wire shark schriftgröße umgestellt
wo geht das überhaupt das hier appearance und 18 massive das vielleicht bis sie bis sie zu fett
auf 14 ok so ist gut so ist schön so lassen wir das massive font ok also was haben wir
schönes zu bieten ich mach das mal kurz auf den eigenen desktop wenn es sonst das fenster
ist ja sticky doch hier unten stört es nicht aber hier unten ist der chat da kommt das fenster hin
an sticky und auf acht auf neun nein das fenster nicht verschieben ich will es ansticken das
fenster jetzt ist es anstickt ok sehr gut also wire shark was haben wir denn hier dhcp wir
machen dhcp das ist schon mal nichts nichts neues so irgendwelche gedöns was mich nicht
interessiert so dann will das ding zum google dns um guckt mal da um pool punkt ntp punkt
org aufzulösen ja dem kann geholfen werden und amazon punkt komm warum will der amazon
punkt kommt also ich würde ja sagen normalerweise aws aber aws ist doch nicht ww punkt kommt warum
will der amazon punkt kommt wer zu besos in weltraum so aus irgendwelchen gründen amazon punkt kommt
und dann möchte er zu irgendeiner china vermute ich jetzt mal china chinesen ip per dhcp das soll
wahrscheinlich später mal htp request werden schauen wir mal was ist das für eine ip boah
mein wire shark ist so fett ich erkenne überhaupt nichts mehr alter so ihr source ip destination
ip copy value da schauen wir mal was dahinter steckt was steckt denn hinter dieser ip
ltd alles klar wo ist wobei hu ist wird mir wahrscheinlich allzu viel bringen ok doch
tatsächlich moment china china alli soft dass die aliexpress klaut dass die aliexpress klaut
china building die 5f cm alles klar aliexpress klaut beijing
wunderbar die könnte man jetzt einfach mal anrufen und fragen was sache ist
security trouble das muss finde ich aber gut dass sie da tatsächlich noch ansprechpartner drin stehen
haben also ich weiß aus eigener erfahrung ist ganz praktisch als ich noch beim provider als
ich eine weile her gearbeitet habe hatten wir einmal einen gehackermenten wordpress server mit
irgendeiner ural pap wordpress version und also der hat uns die ganze zeit anfragen geschickt
haben wir dann geguckt ok von wo kommt das und haben dann beim anderen provider angerufen haben
gesagt ihr habt eine wordpress aber da komische dinger macht also manchmal ist es nicht schlimm
manchmal ist es gut dass es da drin steht ok also aliexpress wir wissen bescheid das ding
verbindet sich zu aliexpress das ja schon mal ganz besonders toll der vertrauenswürdig leute
super vertrauenswürdig wenn erst mal die erste verbindung die ins internet kommt eine verbindung
nach ali nach nach china zu aliexpress ist das ist sowas super vertrauenswürdig ok was haben
wir hier zu bieten google dns google dns bei du ist das nicht auch in china chinesen suchmaschinen
anbieter amazon ok sekunde mal was fragt er alles ab ntp amazon ntp cdn rtp update eko wird
net das ist garantiert für firme update oder sowas wie das ding verbunden ist das ding ist
verbunden mit leute wo da hier mit diesem access point da unten ist es gerade verbunden nur dass
auf dem access point alles geblockt ist ausgehen das kommt nirgends wohin deswegen deswegen siehst
du wir sagen dann auch keine antworten weil das nirgends wohin kommt das will zu eko wird
stimmt nefel oder zu diesem wetterdienst für wetterdaten uploaden ja ok wo willst denn sonst
noch in ntp bach ein wo ich glaube das probiert einfach ein paar sachen durch time punkt windows
punkt komm also ich würde jetzt mal vermuten wenn es pool punkt ntp punkt org auflösen kann
dann brauche es teilen punkt windows punkt komm nicht mehr würde ich jetzt mal drauf tippen
was los chat ja copy paste china chinesen zeug ist vielleicht aktuell nicht so sinnvoll so bei
du windows amazon bei du ok dieser krampel da alles ist ok das ding will wirklich krampfhaft
ntp time haben vielleicht reicht es doch wenn ich einfach mein ntp server verwende da bin ich mal
gespannt alter wie was macht wie viel dns anfragen sind es denn bitteschön das ding
spammt ja dns anfragen es fack hört ja gar nicht mehr auf kockisches mann das hört nicht
mehr auf mit dns anfragen so tcp nach aliexpress das haben wir schon gesehen udp für was macht es
da noch broadcast das broadcast zeugs easyweather wifi id das ding hat auch kein wifi access hat
es ein wifi access point jetzt aufgemacht das ding moment das muss ich mal kurz überprüfen
keck keck weh das ding hat kein wifi access point aufgemacht fake news ok aus irgendwelchen
gründen wahrscheinlich ist das so was wie die weiß discovery oder sowas aus irgendwelchen
gründen broadcast ist auch noch irgendwelchen krampel über udp alles klar sondern versuchen
wir erstmal ntp zum laufen zu bekommen würde ich sagen das heißt wir biegen mal ntp um
mach ich das jetzt am besten sekunde leute ich überlege gerade läuft denn da überhaupt
ein ach so hat mal kurz seck und das webinterface ob ich das webinterface da was verteile ich
denn für einen ntp server verteile ich überhaupt ntp server ich meine ich könnte auch mal
ein dns benutzen auf dem router na 1 2 3 alleine bringt nichts ich muss erstmal die namen auflösen
ne kann man in der app nicht einstellen also ich verwende standardmäßig den da was habe
ich denn hier für einträge kann man ausschalten dass der dns weiterleitet ich will ja kein
dns weiterleiten wir machen statische dns auflösung einfach wir leiten mal ich will
ich will nicht dass der ins internet weitergeht ok wir probieren erstmal kurz ob man dns server
umstellen kann ich stelle jetzt mal dns aber um auf 1.1.1 der geht auch nicht aber ich
will checken ob die china chinesen den dns server hardcoded haben oder ob der aus meinem
dhcp kommt so und wenn wir dabei sind stellen wir noch ntp server ein 1 2 2 1 6 8 8 8 1
nehme ich den hier vielleicht vielleicht reicht das ja schon das geht da geht zu dem ntp server
der geht zu dem ntp vielleicht geht er zu dem ntp server dem ein paar dhcp wobei das kann man
ganz einfach checken weil jetzt mal ein bisschen netzwerk netzwerk netzwerk know-how chat für die
ganzen iak leute nie für die ganzen fachinformatiker als hubis die nix abschlussprüfung haben wenn
ihr in diesen dhcp request reinguckt dann seht ihr was der client requested und der client
requested aktuell option 53 moment offer ne wo ist denn der request den habe ich nicht
mitgeschnitten leute ok ich kann es euch nicht zeigen ich habe den dhcp request nicht mitgeschnitten
zumindest er kriegt als antwort options dhcp options 53 54 51 und weil ich sowas mal eine
weile gemacht habe weiß ich zufälligerweise aus dem kopf ihr könnt mir das jetzt glauben
oder nicht dass option 52 ntp ist guck ich kann euch das provisen ntp dhcp option 42 nicht 52
ok ich habe mich vertan es 42 nicht 52 naja fast immerhin aber erst mal wichtig getan als
müßt nichts oder ok es ist 42 aber 42 wird auch nicht bequestet ja probieren wir das mal
aus also wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben wir gehen in den router konfig sagen ihm hier
neuer dhcp dns und ntp server und jetzt machen wir den stecker sekunde ich mache es mal wieder
sticky jetzt machen wir den stecker raus und den stecker wieder rein und diesmal ich glaube
wir brauchen das nicht im wire shark ich glaube hiermit reicht das auch und jetzt gucken wir
uns das hier an source ip 1216 wobei ich schneide es lieber mit im wire shark im wire shark kann
man sich jetzt einfach schöner angucken also start packets auf jetzt gucken wir mal hierzu
gut ich muss neu starten leute stopp und jetzt start und zack raus und zack rein grad gachi pass so
also diesmal habe ich alles dabei was dhcp ist guck mal er geht zu 111 das heißt ich kann den
dns relativ einfach im dhcp umbiegen auf meinen dns easy und wenn er auf meinen dns geht dann ist
er eigentlich alles gut aber für meinen ntp server interessiert er sich nicht wenn er sich
für meinen ntp server interessieren würde gebe es ab und zu anfragen auf ntp port was ist das
port 123 an diese ip aber das interessiert ihn nicht destination port hier dns dns wie wild macht
der dns aber ansonsten nix ok dann bringen wir unserem dns mal folgendes bei ntp.pool.org ist
er selber 122 168 88.1 gut und jetzt muss ich erst mal kurz gucken wo man hier ntp einschaltet
das habe ich wo macht man hier ntp das ist nicht ip tools time wo gibt es die settings für
wo gibt es die settings für ntp mikrotik ntp server war das standardmäßig gar nicht dabei
war das vielleicht so muss man das nachinstallieren was ist das das ist das frontend von router os das
ist das ist weird champ aber du kannst alles mögliche damit machen ntp server und client
ja ntp server settings system ntp server what the fuck da hätte ich im leben nicht reingeguckt
system nope wo ist der ntp server habe ich alles pool.ntp ist nee es ist pool.ntp genau
pool.ntp.org
router os hat schon immer einen desktop client das ist winbox das gibt schon ewig router
das kannst du über comando zeile über winbox mit comando zeile über oder über webinterface
machen ok wie kriege ich ntp server drauf ich glaube das war ein extra package oder
gucken wir mal also per comando zeile wird man das dann so machen system ntp client es
gibt nur ntp client ok also ich muss irgendwie ntp server auf mein access point kriegen
der ist ja standardmäßig anscheinend nicht dabei tools packages oh gott wie ging das
noch mal packages kein ntp check for updates leute guckt mal buildtime 2018 check for updates
ntp connection timeout ich habe ja ich habe ja alles geblockt ins internet firewall technisch
aber das muss auch so sein weil weil egal 2018 das ist schon uralt wie kriege ich jetzt
ntp server her mikrotik ntp server packet zusätzliches package installieren ok mikrotik
packages leute wisst ihr was ich mache jetzt einfach mal kurz aus ich mache das ding aus
dann gehe ich in meine firewall settings und erlaubt dem mal kurz ins internet zu gehen
für updates weil ich habe einfach gesagt moment das müsste doch aber eigentlich trotzdem
funktionieren habe ich naddi aktiviert nö ist auch da eigentlich richtig so egal disable
check for updates durch gz ok anscheinend nicht block ich irgendwas unsinnig das müsste
dem router doch eigentlich egal sein in interface forward das ist dem router doch wurscht warum
kann ich nicht updaten keine ahnung alles einschalten aber guck mal hier zählen doch
auch gar keine counter hoch input das bleibt nirgendwo hängen vielleicht ist die version
zu alt dass es überhaupt nicht funktioniert dass es die adresse gar nicht mehr gibt wie
updated man hier was ich hab das schon ewig her egal router os download wir machen erstmal
firmware update die musik ist aus ich brauche ein bisschen geduld macht man hier updates
software support router os current release download jawoll npk alles klar so und wie macht
man da jetzt updates package muss man bestimmt uploaden oder irgendwie so upload oh nee jetzt
muss ich jetzt den wine reinkopieren keck weh downloads wie hieß die datei erstmal
wireshark zumachen router os cp router os ne mikro mikrotik downloads router os hierhin
so upload desktop router os upload läuft und jetzt gut wie macht man damit jetzt firmware
in files kopieren und neu starten das so und das muss das reicht jetzt oder wie check update
geht nicht
ja ja check update funktioniert nicht chat ihr müsst nicht die sachen kopieren die
wir schon längst ausprobiert haben package system package worldbird ist ja ganz schön
ganz schön lang der router darf anscheinend nicht ins internet was ich sehr merkwürdig
finde warum darf doch moment warum darf der router nicht ins internet habe ich irgendwelche
komischen firewall gedöns gemacht ich meine der router selbst ist auf jeden fall ja nicht
wireless und darf der router nicht ins internet ok machen wir mal neues kein forward source
any das müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren
moment
die wlan clients können aber ins internet für den router ist es gibt doch gar kein
output es gibt nur input bei lp t8 moment null cake wait aber das ist das muss doch
funktionieren kann man das dem ok ich habe keine ahnung wobei das müsste doch eigentlich
auch vorwärts sein ich weiß nicht warum ein access point nicht ins internet darf 88 1 müsste
eigentlich aber ich habe keine ahnung warum der nicht ins internet kommt ja der müsste
eigentlich aber aus irgendwelchen gründen bleibt er hängen da kann er sich wenigsten
selbst pingen was gut was auch immer
das
Wenn wir auch sagen nur Files Menü, File List ja, hab ich, hab ich und dann einfach
Rebooten?
Moment das war's, einfach neu starten, das ist alles?
Ja gut, kann ich mit leben!
Starten wir die Kiste hier drüber, eigentlich neu, kann man einfach so sagen, Reboot?
Ne, äh, Re-Redo, ach keine Ahnung, ich kann MikroTik, Kommando, Zeilenkrempel nicht, äh
System?
Zur Sicherheit erst auf die neueste 6er, meinste, der mag sonst nicht, ich, warum kommt, warum
kommt mein, also die Kleins kommen ins Internet, die Kleins kommen ins Internet, warum kommt
der Access Point, das ist doch das eigentliche Problem, warum kommt der Access Point nicht
ins Internet, das ist doch sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Warum kommt der Access Point nicht ins Internet, okay, wir waren jetzt bei einer Sache, easy,
wir waren jetzt bei einer Sache, wir erlauben jetzt einfach mal alles, ich mein, es ist
ja grad nix eingeschaltet, apply, daran liegt es nicht, es liegt nicht an Firewall-Regeln,
aber die Kleins kommen ins Internet, hm, woran könnte das liegen, es müsste eigentlich
so funktionieren, doch, doch, wenn der kein Geld mehr hätte, würde es doch ansonsten
gar nicht weiter funktionieren, ich hab keine Ahnung, der holt sich per DHCP von meinem
Router die Adresse und nuttet die Sachen raus, das muss eigentlich funktionieren, ist WLAN
ausgeschaltet, nein, nein, es ist nicht ausgeschaltet, äh, wait a minute, was ist denn das, es kann
ich aus, Moment, warte mal, warum ist das aus, weil, nein, das ist die DHCP, nein, nein,
nein, das ist die DHCP-Liste, das ist die Adressliste fürs DHCP im WLAN, das hat damit
überhaupt nix zu tun, ich hab keine Ahnung, warum der nicht ins Internet kann, das ist
jetzt zwar nicht das, womit ich mich beschäftigen wollte, aber das würde mich jetzt doch mal
interessieren, kriegt man denn für dieses alte Zeug, ich meine, ich brauch doch nur
ein NTP, Interfaces, Interfaces gibt's hier, der macht auch Dinger,
und die WLAN-Kleins, solange ich die Firewall nicht an hab, können ins Internet, das heißt,
das ist prinzipiell in Ordnung, warum kann der Router selbst nicht, versteh ich nicht,
ja, das ist klar, dass er sich nicht pingen kann, wenn die nicht, aber, aber warum, stimmt,
da müsste ich vielleicht mal hier 8888 ausprobieren oder so, stimmt, ich pinge das Falsche, so,
und jetzt machen wir das nochmal an, der kommt nicht raus, ich hab keine Ahnung, warum, oh,
Ramos ist da, Leute, ich muss kurz runter, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich hab keine Ahnung,
ich bin gleich wieder da, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich bin
wieder da, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich bin gleich wieder da, ich bin groß, ich bin
das hat gewartet wenn ich unten war
also an meinen fireball einstellungen liegt es nicht
ich hab jetzt überhaupt keinen bock ehrlich gesagt
mich darum zu kümmern weil ich einfach nur NTPs aber
drauf haben wollte aber es muss doch
möglich sein
dem ding beizubringen
ich mein wo blockt der das
denn
gar nicht oder input
das landet
in keiner fireball chain und nichts
ich überleg grad ob der fehler
nicht davor liegt
gucken wir mal
das dürfte er selber
sein gut das funktioniert
außerhalb also
pingen wir mal mich an
gut das ist meine ip die kann
er nicht
weil weil getroppt
wird
aber
ich mein jetzt kann noch nichts mal getroppt werden
jetzt ist alles erlaubt von dem ding
check
nicht
und das jetzt verstehen
extra package aber
warum kommt das ding
das sind doch irgendwelche merkwürdige
natt settings die hier ab die hier rum
rumspacken oder
out interface
das hab ich nicht angelegt das ist standard
config
das problem
ist nicht mein netzwerk
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche komischen natt settings von dem ding
was auch immer das
was auch immer das macht
das ist weil es halt komisch ist
weil ich
darf das ding pingen das funktioniert
aber das ding darf mich nicht pingen
was wiederum heißt
dass irgendwo was geplockt wird
ich mein
ach moment ist das so was meine ip
sack
moment was hab ich denn hier für einen blödsinn eingestellt
warum hab ich denn hier kein kein
warum ist meine vm hier über natt
was das für ein schwachsinn
pff
hä
seit wann
bridged
seit wann ist das über natt das hab ich ja noch nie
blödsinn braucht keiner
so
haben wir jetzt für eine ip
das sieht doch schon mal besser aus
normalerweise hab ich die 220
keine ahnung warum ich das ding umgestellt hab
ja ok
reconnect
das ist schon besser
das hat aber nichts damit zu tun
dass er nicht nach außen kann
ok das funktioniert
das nach außen geht
aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht
1.1 hätten wir bei mir im netzwerk noch zu bieten
warum geht das nicht
der geht
mit seiner internet ip raus
mein restliches netzwerk sollte das überhaupt
nicht interessieren
das leuchtet mir nicht ein
das ist auf jeden fall irgendwas dahinter
das hat nichts mit dem
accesspoint zu tun
tja ich hab keine ahnung
was mach ich denn jetzt am besten
mach ich jetzt irgendein sinnloses update
dass das ding ins internet kommt
könnte das denn liegen
ich mein geplockt ist nichts
keine ahnung
routing tabelle
das ist ne gute idee
hält sichs ja in grenzen
ja genau
das sollte alles natten über
das ist mein internes netz
die clients kommen ins internet
übergehen
deswegen leuchtet mir das überhaupt nicht ein
warum der intern schonmal nix pingen kann
an irgendeiner rückroute
kanns auch nicht liegen weil der hat ne
interne ip drinne
ich hasse es ultra
gebackseited zu werden
so ich hab keine ahnung woran das liegt
kann das sein
dass das
dass die nattgeschichte
für ihn selbst
irgendwie nicht greift
mach erstmal nen reboot
dass das da dran liegt
ok bis ich das hingebastelt hab
sind wir morgen
jaja connect
gib ihm
wir updaten jetzt
mal schauen
ob das funktioniert
system
outinterface für snutt
ist wahn
naja das ist das was dieses autoconfig
ding damals angelegt hat
ich hab mir schon überlegt ob ich nicht einfach
rausschmeiße jetzt
aber
da müsste ich zudem wieder komplett neu einrichten
ja outinterface
das ist die
das ist wahrscheinlich das
interface list
eth1 ja das ist das
einzige netzwerk interface
was es hat
meine clients werden über natürlich die die
im wlan sind schon
also warum das nicht funktioniert verstehe ich wirklich nicht
hat man da nicht irgendwie nen
traceroot oder so
noch mal gucken können
ich weiß zumindest er selbst sollte mal
in dem traceroot drinstehen
aber
ich weiß nicht
selbst sollte mal in dem traceroot drinstehen
oder
ich hab wirklich keinen plan
woran das liegt
wir machen jetzt nen reboot und
hoffen dass das alles passt
yes
schauen wir mal
nach dem reboot nicht mal
funktionieren naja gut
wenn er nach dem reboot nicht mal funktioniert
dann können wir neu einrichten da kann ich resetten
und gut ist
steht da standardmäßig auf
ip holen oder nicht
oder gibt er sich seine komische aesthetic
ip wieder
also er blinkt wie verrückt rum
das ist erstmal ein gutes zeichen
denke ich
ich guck mal kurz auf den ipad
ob irgendwelche
wifi dinge aufgehen oder so
also der macht noch update
der blinkt ganz abartig
rum gerade
so und jetzt hat er laut router
zumindest wieder netzwerkverbindung
der port war
ne jetzt der port wieder down
ok das ding macht noch update
so auf wie der port gerade ab und
down geht
ich glaube jetzt rebootet der
jetzt ist nämlich alles aus gerade
außer power
außer power alles aus
wir brauchen so ein update auf so ein kleines
accessport also letztes mal
als ich auf dem
auf der anderen kiste lief das
30 sekunden oder so
dann war es wieder da
ding ist ja lahm
da sind wir wieder
pogg
reconnect
zack
guck mal
und sogar die session behalten
na besser
gehts ja nicht hat er denn jetzt überhaupt
geupdatet
ja die icons sehen anders aus leute der muss
geupdatet haben
so kommt er jetzt ins internet
nein muss er aber auch nicht
egal
ok und jetzt brauche ich package download
software
wo gibts denn den kram
ntp server
ne extra packages
das da
oder
brauche ich das hier
ich glaube das hier brauche ich
beim 7er ist es dabei
oh nice
system
ntp ah die haben es tatsächlich
geschafft jetzt nach 100 jahren
ntp server zu integrieren nice
so mag ich das so muss das sein
ok enable
broadcast
multicast enable
local clock was auch immer
aber neue icons haben wir
auch leute neue icons
gut jetzt haben wir nen ntp server an
pogg
ja das dumme ist jetzt wir haben nen ntp server
aber mein router hat kein internet
der kann sich ja gar nichts
aus dem internet gar nichts upstream holen
und die zeit stimmt wahrscheinlich auch nicht
wie lässt man sich die systemzeit
bei dem ding dann anzeigen
kurz hier
terminal time
nein keine ahnung
mikrotik show system
time
system clock
lock
print da
oops
print
wieso
sind diese dinger nie über
kommandozeit keine ahnung
oder einfach da drin jetzt print
aha
nicht
so ganz nicht so ganz
aber ich kann intern von
meinem router setzen lassen
2.50
start jawoll den kann ich
also wenn ich den pingen kann dann muss ich
alles andere doch eigentlich auch pingen können
ja
zumindest kann
ich jetzt system ntp
server
ntp client
enable
bei meinem anderen router als
upstream irgendwie rein
nein nein nein
50 so rum
so
aha
wir haben eine richtige
Uhrzeit Leute
ok jetzt
können wir mit der eigentlichen Geschichte weitermachen
also wir haben eine ntp server an
ja also wir haben
ntp server an
auf auf
local host also hier auf
sagt mal warum hat das
wlan interface eigentlich keine ip
ip
das muss doch eigentlich auch eine ip
haben
ja
es sind die
Liste
Was sehr merkwürdig ist, dass der sich nicht mal selbst pingen kann.
Da ist doch irgendwas.
Er kackt, oder?
Quickset.
Okay, was haben wir da zu bieten?
Passwort zeigen wir nicht.
Local IP 880.1 Warum hat er denn kein...
Angeblich hat er Nutt und hat doch wieder keins?
Hä?
Die Settings ergeben keinen Sinn, oder?
Der sollte eigentlich alles ausgehende Nutten, was man ja auch bei den Nutt-Settings gesehen
hat, aber irgendwie macht er das nicht.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ja ja, ist schon okay, ich mag das bloß nicht, wenn man 50x gleiche spammt und meine Klicks
fernsteuern will.
Oh!
By the way, was passiert, Chat, seid ihr schon eingeloggt?
Also ich hab keine Ahnung.
Na gut, das erklärt zumindest auch, warum er nicht ins Internet kommt.
Aber dass er seine lokale IP pingen können sollte, das sollte noch eigentlich funktionieren.
Aber das funktioniert auch nicht.
Geil, Alter.
Häkchen bei Nutt?
Fortmapping?
Zumindest.
Jetzt sollte man eigentlich... ah, okay, er hat die Verbindung verloren, alles klar.
Jetzt muss er noch mal neu starten, wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung.
Kann sein, dass ICMP im Standard deaktiviert ist?
Stimmt, das ist tatsächlich möglich, wahrscheinlich ist ICMP deaktiviert, hast recht.
Äh, startet er sich jetzt gerade neu, oder?
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ach, ich hab mich vertippt, cool, man sieht das bloß nicht.
Okay, kein Schimmer.
Dann mach ich das Nutt mal wieder raus, so, dann geben wir mal Input, Input, äh, Protokoll
ICMP, so, äh, nein, nein, nein, nein, achtennachtspunkt1, ich hab keine Ahnung, was an dieser Konfig
so verkackt ist, dass die einfachsten Dinger nicht funktionieren, achso, enable, lul, okay
funktioniert.
Okay, Ping ist erlaubt, alles gut, also wunderbar, jetzt können wir weitermachen, wenigstens
das, NTP ist am Start, DNS ist am Start, okay, was, was mach ich jetzt, wie krieg ich den
jetzt, wie krieg ich den jetzt dazu überredet, mein DNS zu benutzen, beziehungsweise will
ich, will ich überhaupt, dass der mein DNS benutzt, weil mein DNS leitet ja im Zweifelsfall
weiter sonst wo hin, ich stell mein DNS einfach mal auf irgendwas ein, was es nicht gibt,
kann nämlich nix passieren.
So, ähm, so, der kann jetzt eigentlich, okay, pool.ntp.org sollte er jetzt auflösen können,
was hatte der denn sonst noch, was wollte der sonst noch haben, CDNRTP Update oder irgendwie
sowas, time.windows, ja, ich hoffe, dass wenn er pool.ntp.org auflösen kann, ja, mach's
gut, DrFresher, ähm, wenn der das auflösen kann, wir brauchen noch, der hatte noch Amazon,
immerzu löse ich ihm nicht auf, so, Wireshark, der hatte doch hier noch sowas, der hatte
doch noch irgendeine Geschichte drinnen mit, das da, China, China-Chinesen-IP und, nee,
was war das andere nochmal, CDNRTP Update, okay, Domain, wo ist das, wo war das denn drin
stehen, Queries, das da, Copy Value, das ist ein Wetterdienst, weiß ich nicht, was passiert
denn da, Perl, wo komm ich denn hier raus jetzt, Moment, welcome to CodeIgniter, der
muss den, der muss ich bei den China-Chinesen melden, ja, ja, ich seh's schon, okay, wir
machen jetzt mal folgendes, ich hab, ich hab 5-Headige-Idee, ähm, mein Rechner konnte
ich pingen, ne, mein Rechner konnte ich pingen hier, 2.12, ich werd den, ich werd den Access
Point, ja, passt, nochmal neu, neu aufsetzen fürs nächste Mal, weil das ist ja total verkackt
die Konfig, so, und dann sagen wir ihm jetzt einfach mal, das da wird aufgelöst auf das
da, das geht zwar netzwerktechnisch noch nicht, aber ich vermute mal, der schickt dort irgendwelche
Requests hin und diese Requests werd ich einfach abgreifen mit nem Netcat auf meine
Linux-Kiste, müssen wir aber erstmal mitschneiden auf welchem Port, ähm, Moment, da brauchen
wir, brauchen wir irgendeine Firewall-Regel für, dass das funktioniert, Firewall-Regel,
also wir wollen forward, erlauben, source, 8.8.174, oder was war das, für die DHCP-Server,
dieses 251, also das ist die IP von der Wetterstation und der darf zu 1.2.1.6.8.2.1.2.7,
das ist meine Kiste hier, so, Protokoll, TCP, Rest lass ich mal offen, Rest lass ich mal
offen, achja, NTP muss ich noch erlauben, NTP muss ich noch erlauben, Input, Destination,
ja, aber hier gehen wir nicht so aus, 1.2.1.2, ist NTP Broadcast? Ja, wir machen grad Gatschi-Buzz
mit der Wetterstation, mit der da, guck mal, Picture in Picture, der Wetterstation hier,
hier wird die Kundin abgekackt, Input, Protokoll, was ist denn, 1.1.3, gell, 1.2.3, UDP, was
ist, was ist das, NTP Port, UDP und TCP, meinetwegen, kann man beides machen, ok, Apply, ok,
man kann sich vom Access Point, was, NTP holen, das ist glaube ich erlaubt, das kann man so
drin stehen lassen, ok, alles klar, so, dann starten wir das doch mal neu und schauen was
passiert, Taggats, Start, achso, machen wir mal kurz hier eine Netcat auf, Netcat minus
Port minus Listen auf 80, geh mal davon aus, es ist HTTP, minus Listen minus Port, ja,
Port 80, Listen, so, was macht der denn, Destination, 53, 53, ach, ich hab den DHCP noch nicht umgebogen
Leute, zack, Strom raus, IP, DHCP Server, Wetter, Konsole, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
hier, NTP Server, juckt ihr nicht, DNS Server, 1.2.1.2.8, Moment, DNS muss ich auch noch erlauben,
Alter Firewall Stellz, hör mal auf, du bist ja verrückt, ja, NTP ist doch UDP, oder, oder
beides, ja, das sehen wir gleich, Input, Input, Input, Input, Input, Protokoll, TCP, nee,
UDP, das ist ja DNS, Port 53, Apply, kurz checken, nick, cool.ntp.org, 1.2.1.7, ja,
guckt, DNS Anfrage löst es zu der lokalen IP auf, gut, ja, dann schalten wir das doch
jetzt mal, stopp, schalten wir das doch jetzt mal ein und gucken, was passiert, so, hier
tut sich noch gar nichts, Packages, 1.1.1.1, was, hä, hab ich verklickt, DHCP Server,
Apply Works, apply, ah, ich hab nicht Applied, da ist er, jetzt aber, so, ok, jetzt gucken
wir den mal zu, was macht er denn, Port 80, immer noch auf dieser kack IP, ok, wir müssen
gleich Wire sharken, ich sehe, was ist denn das, Moment, 88, na, das ist ja eher, jetzt
versucht er sonst, wohin zu gehen, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2,
60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 60.2, 65.2, 65.2, 60.2, 65.2,
67.2, 67.2, 67.2, 67.2, 67.2, 78.2, 78.2, 68.2, 78.2, 78.2, 78.2, 78.2, 78 e-paper wrestler,
Die Wetterstation spricht mit mir!
MacLeague!
Das ist ja äußerst interessant!
Wo möchte die Wetterstation denn hin? Das bauen wir doch jetzt mal nach, Curl!
Mal gucken, was die China Cloud antwortet, wenn ich diese Anfrage schicke. Wo steht die Wetterstation?
Also die Konsole, mit der wir reden, steht hier neben mir. Die Wetterstation selbst ist auf der Garage, obendrauf, die Außenstation.
So, dann setzen wir das doch jetzt mal ab. Also, wo müssen wir hin?
CDN RTP. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Postrequest. xpost.cdnrtpecovid.net
Slash data. Wie heißt die Station? Das ist das Ding. Also das ist der Original China Hersteller.
Die findest du auf Amazon unter 30 anderen Herstellern. Stop. Trauma. Vielleicht nachher.
Also die findest du wirklich auf Amazon für um die 130 Euro unter zig Herstellern.
Das ist alles reprinted. IP? IP? IP? AP?
Mac Missing. OK. Das ist die China API hier oben. Mac Missing. OK. Und Mac gleich. 111111111111.
1-1-1?
Pass auf, jetzt habe ich die Chinesen blacklisted.
Error was?
Äh, okay.
Ach, Moment, ich habe einmal 1-1 zu viel, null.
An Error was encountered.
Na gut, dann...
Ach, was mache ich denn da?
Will so wilde gehackt werden?
Naja, weil du ansonsten die China Cloud verwenden willst, musst.
Das ist ja ein Postrequest, minus D, weil ansonsten musst du die China Cloud verwenden
und ich...
Also nach dem, was ich hier in meinem Package, Packet Dump gesehen habe, will ich glaube
ich das Ding nicht ins Internet hängen.
Invalid Mac, okay, wir chibaden den jetzt, wir chibaden, Leute, ich mache da nicht meine
echte Mac.
Ich chibade den, äh, A, 7, 1F, 8, 1, A6, 3, A, der will nicht, dann machen wir die
anderen Krempel auch nochmal hinten dran.
Invalid Mac, die ist zu kurz, aber vielleicht muss der Anfang stimmen.
Ne, das ist doch hier, das ist doch, das ist doch, ein Block zu wenig, 1, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, noch richtig, ach ne, ha, 0, ist nicht richtig, sind da 6 Stück, äh, 1, 1.
Hey, guck mal, die China Api spricht mit uns, das muss man also antworten, da kommt
die Zeit her, ne, da kommt die Zeitzone her, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Hä,
so, also, nur da ich das jetzt verstehe, also die Chinesen machen das so, über NTP holen
sie sich die Zeit, dann schicken sie ein Request, die Zeitzone zurück anhand der Absender
IP der, des Clients, also, also die, die Chinesen gucken von welcher IP ich das absende und
haben da ne Datenbank, wo drin steht, diese IP kommt wohl aus Deutschland, dann matchen
sie das auf irgendwas internes und geben dieses hier als JSON zurück, deswegen geht die Zeit
auch nur, wenn man im Internet ist mit der Station, das ergibt Sinn, dann wisst ihr
was, ich lass mein Netcat einfach mal antworten, ähm, Echo, tja, man weiß nicht ob das, ob
das alles ist, ja, Echo, äh, Sekunde, wie mach ich das, ist eigentlich gut so, Hype,
ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher, ob das mit Netcat, ähm, Simple, App Server,
das ist Gbait, das funktioniert nicht, über den Stack Overflow Eintrag bin ich schon öfters
gestolpert, es ist, ähm, nicht das BSD Netcat, es ist hier, passt, also ist das eigentlich
richtig, was ich mache, ne, was ist das Problem, achso, ich hab's wieder falsch rum, ich kann,
noob, so und jetzt resetten wir nochmal und gucken, ob da sich die Zeit holt, bin ich
ja mal gespannt, probier als Field mal Total Rain Millimeter, wie wo als Field, an die
Schiene AP oder was, hier, also du meinst jetzt noch hier hinten dran oder wie, Total
Rain Millimeter, juckt den überhaupt nicht, auf, schick dein Request und krieg deine Zeitzone,
Pregge, Leute, Pregge, dass das funktioniert, Pregge, es bleibt leer, ja gut, woher sollen
die auch meinen Total Rain wissen, woher sollen denn die Schiene AP meinen Regen wissen, Leute,
die Uhrzeit ist da, Pog, oh, ich hab, ich hab, oh, Moment, ich hab irgendwas gedrückt
gerade da unten jetzt, was hab ich denn gedrückt, ich resette nochmal kurz, Zack, zu viel Enthusiasmus,
oh, Moment, NC, oh, Wild, True, True, Done, das kenn ich, Danos, ich verwende später das
da, eGitHub, eCovid, Home Assistant, es gibt eine komplette Home Assistant Integration,
das ist überhaupt, ja, so wirklich krasses Gehecke ist das hier jetzt ja nicht, wir gucken
uns ein bisschen Netzwerk Traffic an und basteln dann was rum, also, irgendwelche Debug, irgendwelche
Debug Sachen und Hex Editor gibt es heute nicht, so, das Ding werde ich dann verwenden
für meine Home Assistant, aber ich wollte unter anderem diese Station eben ordentlich
verwenden können und diese Station kann man nur verwenden, wenn man sie ins Internet packt
gescheit, außer wir faken die API von den China-Chinesen, der Chat wieder super freundlich
heute so wie es aussieht, Korn, das ist, nimmst dir nicht zu Herzen, das so ist der Chat manchmal,
guck mal, es hat die Uhrzeit gesetzt, da, 15.10 Uhr und es funktioniert, nice, das ist ein
Anfängliche Netzwerk Problem, ich bin begeistert, so, das, ok, ich fasse mal zusammen, damit
man diese Wetterstation sinnvoll betreiben kann, braucht man eine Wetterstation die draußen
auf der Garage steht und diese Konsole, ok, damit diese Konsole ordentlich funktioniert,
muss sie NTP bekommen, allerdings, bitte schön, nicht von einem lokalen NTP, sondern von pool.ntp.org,
den ich im DNS umbiegen muss, das Datum stimmt doch, 7.05, das ist doch richtig, guck, 7.05,
geht er jede Sekunde ins Internet für die Uhrzeit, ne, so wie ich das verstehe, so wie
ich das verstehe, holt er sich über den NTP-Server die Uhrzeit und was er sich aus dem Internet
holt, ist nur die Zeitzone, was macht der da überhaupt, achja, die Zeitzone, der holt
sich nur die Zeitzone, dass es Europe Berlin ist, Offset zu UTC und DST1, was auch immer,
Sunrise und Sunset holt er sich, Sunrise und Sunset ändert sich, ja, ach das ist ob Sommerzeit
oder Winterzeit ist das eins, das heißt, was ich jetzt bräuchte ist eigentlich nur,
auf meinem Raspberry Pi irgendein kleines Skript, was zu der China-Chinesen-RP geht,
sich dort einmal am Tag oder so die Daten abruft und dann weiterproxied quasi zu meiner
lokalen Wetterstation, weil das Ding, ganz im Ernst, chat, eine Frage an euch, nachdem
ihr jetzt gesehen habt, was das Ding erstmal für Connections macht, von Amazon bis Baidu
bis AliExpress bis eCovid bis sonst was und irgendwie 100 verschiedene DNS-Namen, würdet
ihr das Ding ins Internet hängen bei euch, ruhigen Gewissens und würdet euch denken,
alles klar, passt schon oder würdet ihr auch gucken, dass es möglichst nicht ins Internet
kommt, prozentig nicht, ich mein, die Chancen, dass wirklich was Schlimmes passiert, sind
nicht hoch, denke ich, aber warum? Und wisst ihr, was ich ein bisschen bescheuert finde,
dass man hier nicht einfach sagen kann, Zeitzone einstellen in der App, das geht in der App
nicht, ich hab's aus, du kannst Zeitzone nicht einstellen in der App und dann einfach ein
lokaler NTP über DHCP reicht, easy, fertig. Das könnte so einfach sein, ja?
Das könnte so easy sein, ist es aber nicht. Was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn ich den
Web-Server jetzt hier unten ausmache? Ja gut, wenn ich den Web-Server ausmache, dann wird
das nächste Mal einfach nicht funktionieren, logisch. Das heißt, ich bräuchte jetzt irgendwie
einen Raspberry Pi oder sowas, was das macht. Oder noch besser. Leute, ich hab eine Idee,
ich hab eine Idee, wir können noch was kleines programmieren. Also, guckt mal, ich erzähl
das mal, was ich vor hab, nicht dass ich Mist erzähle. Also, was ich jetzt ja aktuell mache
ist, 5-Hat-Time, genau. Also, das, was ich jetzt ja aktuell mache, ist folgendes. Per
DHCP bekommt die Wetterstation gesagt, dass sie diesen DNS-Server verwenden soll. Dieser
DNS-Server kann nur eine IP auflösen, zwei IPs auflösen. Nämlich cdn-rtp-ecovid zeigt
dann auf die 192.168.2.127 und poolntp.org zeigt auf 192.168.881. Nachdem ich den ja
normalerweise so nicht im Access-Point drin hab, ich könnte doch, nur mal rein von der
Idee her, ich könnte doch irgendein.NET-Programm machen mit einem Web-Server, das im Hintergrund
immer das China-Chinesen-Ding aktualisiert und ausliefert, und mit einem eingebauten
DNS-Server, der einfach nur diese zwei IPs auflöst. Und das lass ich dann auf irgendeinem
x-bliebigen internen Raspberry Pi laufen und bieg nur für diese Lease von der Wetterstation
in den DNS-Server um. Also, gucken wir mal, ob das von der Theorie her funktionieren würde,
was ich mir vorstelle. Weil das hier ist jetzt ja nur ein Test-Ex... Wie viele Raspberry
Pies hast du aktuell? Nicht so viele. Ich hab einen im Keller stehen, ich hab einen
am 3D-Drucker stehen und ich hab einen... Wobei, der im Wohnzimmer ist aktuell auf der
Abschussliste. Drei Stück. Ich hab einen im Wohnzimmer für Fernsehaufnahmen. Du hörst
nix mehr? Das ist gebaited, weil Raspberry Pi und keiner jemand bekommt aktuell. Das
ist massive gebaited. Ja. Sekunde. Also, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben? Also, ich
hab einen 3D-Drucker an Raspberry Pi im Wohnzimmer, der die Fernsehaufnahmen macht und im Keller
auf einen. Nein, und noch einen, der aktuell im Wohnzimmer stehen Unify-Controller macht.
Warum nimmst du für Sunrise, Sunset nicht einfach eine Library, aber Pifadge der YOLO
fand. Massify IQ der YOLO fand. Ja, das ist eigentlich noch besser. Oder ich frag meine
Heimautomatisierung einfach von Sunrise und Sun. Das machen wir jetzt. Okay. Der Raspberry
Pi im Keller, der ist für die Heizung, der ist mit einem... Wie heißt das Ding? Automation
Head, mit einem Automation P-Head ausgestattet und greife dort mit Analog-Digital-Wandler
die Spannung von meiner Tür-Gegensprechanlage ab. Und wenn die Spannung der Tür-Gegensprechanlage
auf 22 Volt steigt, dann hat einer geklingelt und dann ruft es mich per SIP auf dem Handy
an und dann gehe ich aufs Handy und nehme ab in der VoIP-App und dann nimmt das zusätzlich
noch die Kamera, die ich bei mir an der Straße hängen habe und packt die mir in den SIP-Anruf
dabei. Das heißt, ich kann dann unterwegs, werde ich von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage angerufen,
nehme an und sehe, wer vor der Tür steht. Ich habe auch schon mal eingebaut, dass man
mit den Leuten sprechen kann, die unten vor der Tür stehen. Aber das habe ich wieder
ausgebaut, weil das verwende ich nie und ich kann auf dieses komische Siedle-Endgerät
verzichten, was man braucht für Kommunikation mit Telefon. Der Pi ist... Das ist ein Octoprint,
genau. Doch, doch, der Octoprint könnte auf meinem Server mitlaufen. Da müsste ich einfach
USB dran. Da steht jetzt ja unten dran. Aber früher stand der 3D-Drucker neben dem Abstellraum
und der Server hier hinten im Serverraum. Deswegen ging das nicht. Aber ja, du hast
recht, den Octopi bräuchte ich jetzt gar nicht mehr. Das ist eigentlich ein guter Hinweis,
Chet. Das schreibe ich mir mal auf. Warum sollte ich den Octopi verwenden, wenn ich
noch den Server direkt unten drunter stehen habe? Ja, also wir könnten was programmieren,
Leute. Das machen wir jetzt. Nur mal testen, ob das von der Idee her funktioniert. Ich
sage dem Ding jetzt einfach, verwende mal als DNS-Server. Wie überschreibt man DNS-Server
in den Leases? Leases? DHCP-Options. Chet, wer ist so pfeifertig und weiß aus dem Kopf
DHCP-Option für DNS-Server? DHCP-Server-DNS-Option. Option 53 oder sowas? Option 15? 5? Nee,
die 53 ist der Port. 42 ist NTP. Mikrotik, Lease, Override, DNS. 6? Option? Es ist Option
6, hat man vorher im Wireshark gesehen. Nächster Pfeif-Header-Zuschauer, wir können einfach
im Wireshark gucken. Wir gucken einfach im Wireshark, was es war. DHCP-Offer. Option.
6? Name-Server. Yep. Yep, Coq. Also, Options. DHCP-Options. DNS-Override. Ich muss das Ding
irgendwie so nennen, dass ich es mir noch merken kann. Code 6-Value-12213. Ich leite
das auf meine Linux-Kiste weiter, weil, ja, von da kann ich dann gleich mein.NET-Programm
testen. Okay, Apply. Unknown-Data-Type. Oh, das kenne ich, das hatte ich schon mal. Das
ist irgendwie so eine Mikrotik-Besonderheit gewesen. Da musste das irgendwie prefixen
oder so. Option 6. Team-Server. Die Quauten-Geräte, die ich schon mal gesehen habe, das ist eigentlich
so komisch. Ich glaube, das ist es. Das hatte ich schon mal, das kenne ich, das hatte ich
schon mal so. Ah, ja. Obvious. Obvious-ly. Alles klar. Logisch. Logisch. Single-Quotes.
Natürlich war es sonst nicht logisch. Also, wer das... Cringe, wer das nicht weiß. Okay,
leases. Options-DNS-Override-Apply. Was kannst du an DNS-Empfehlen, wenn man keinen Mikrotik-Mask
und Bein nicht gut funktioniert? Ganz ehrlich, für den Heimbereich, das ist zwar eigentlich
ein DNS-Blocker. Unter der Haube ist es auch DNS-Mask. Das ist zwar eigentlich ein DNS-Werbeblocker,
Edgard Haum hat aber relativ viele Settings, die du einstellen kannst, die unter der Haube
in eine DNS-Mask-Konfig reinkommen, aber halt mit einem schönen Webinterface. Find ich
für den Heimbereich gar nicht schlecht. So, leases. DNS-Override. Gut, von der Idee her...
Moment, läuft hier auf Port 53 was? Nicht, dass ich jetzt auf einmal... Okay, quate.
Nee, läuft nix. Benutz du? Ich benutze entweder 1111 oder 8888. Okay Leute, auf geht's. Checken
wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Start, Packages. Jetzt sollte er sich ja versuchen, per DNS...
Jetzt sollte er sich ja versuchen, per DNS, auf meine Kiste zu verbinden. Sieht gut aus.
53, jawoll, macht er. Ist aber nicht freigeschaltet. Okay, dann schreiben wir das mal um. Ah, es
ist UDP. Na, geil. Wir machen noch Port 80. Destination Port 80 hier rein. Und dann wurschteln
wir das hier um von 12216888. Nee. Wait a minute. Das wird jetzt ja genattet. Nee, wird das
nicht. Wird nicht genattet. Hab ich ausgeschaltet. 88251 auf 1221688827. UDP, Port 53 apply. Okay,
das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas auf Port 53 mache. Netcat. NC minus L minus P
minus U 53, dann kriege ich jetzt zig ab... Minus U. That's dead. Dann kriege ich jetzt
30 Milliarden abfragen. Würde ich jetzt eigentlich erwarten. Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen
kriege ich das nicht. Doch, doch, du kennst, bei AddGuard Home kannst du eigene Einträge
DNS machen. Da gehen auch Sachen drüber hier. Guck, das passt doch. Mein Netcat zeigt mir
halt nix an. Warum auch immer. Warum zeigt mir mein Netcat nix an? Sollte mir das nicht
eigentlich DNS-Request anzeigen jetzt? Rein theoretisch. Vielleicht. Dann gucken wir mal
kurz in den Dump rein. Files, keqw, pcap, download. Ach, es ist immer noch Input, ich
noob. Falsche Chain. Forward. Lull. Da. Baidu. Baidu.com will er auflösen. Gut, funktioniert.
Die Anfragen kommen an. Okay, ich hab noch nie einen DNS-Server gemacht. Ich hab noch
nie einen DNS-Server selbst gebaut. Da gibt's bestimmt fertige Libraries für.NET für,
geh ich mal von aus. So, Campchamp. Neues Projekt. X des Solution wird angelegt. Was
macht der da wieder eine halbe Stunde rum hier? Console-App. Chat. Wir brauchen Name. Wetterchamp,
oder? Wetterchamp ist gut. Wetterchamp. PutSolution. Same directory. Wetterchamp. Okay, wir brauchen
NuGet. NuGet. Packages. Ich muss gucken, was es für DNS-Libraries gibt. Warum ein DNS-Server
in.NET? Naja, weil es muss nicht in.NET sein. Es könnte in irgendwas anderem auch sein.
Weil wir folgendes machen müssen. Die Wetterstation. Warum hab ich 97% CPU-Auslastung? Wahrscheinlich
weil Rider startet. Also die Wetterstation möchte folgendes machen. Die möchte Pool.ntp.org
auflösen. Ich will die aber nicht ins Internet lassen. Das heißt, ich brauch einen DNS-Server,
der Pool.ntp.org zu einem lokalen NTP-Server auflöst. Vielleicht gibt es auch einen NTP
in.NET. Dann machen wir den kompletten Wetterchamp. Alles, was wir brauchen. Äh, gibt es.NET
NTP-Server? Muss ich gleich mal nachgucken. So, zumindest, der muss einmal Pool.ntp.org
auflösen zu irgendeinem lokalen NTP. DNS-Server selbst bauen, ein Request beantworten. Das
ist easy. Gibt es bestimmt fertige Libraries für. So, wenn der NTP auflösen kann, dann
muss der eine gültige NTP-Sache bekommen. Alles gut. Und danach möchte der irgendwelche
Webseiten abrufen aus China. Was natürlich auch nicht funktioniert. Und diese zwei Sachen
müssen wir irgendwie nachbauen. Ich kann das in mein AccessPoint-DNS schreiben. Aber
normalerweise, also den da, aber normalerweise benutze ich diesen AccessPoint nicht. Der
ist zum Testen. Und in meinen normalen Router-DNS will ich das nicht eintragen, weil der dann
automatisch, sobald das China-Chinesen-Ding den normalen DNS verwendest, alles auflösen
kann, weil er ins Internet weiterleitet. Man könnte, das würde auch funktionieren. Du
könntest ein Bind hinstellen, du könntest ein DNS-Mask hinstellen, irgendwas. Es muss
eigentlich nur ein DNS sein, der eine IP auflöst. Aber nachdem wir eh einen Web-Server brauchen,
der die passende China-Antwort zurückschickt, können wir bei der Gelegenheit auch gleich
mal ein.NET-DNS-Server. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Müssen wir mal schauen.
DNS. Da gibt es bestimmt fertige Libraries und das ist ganz easy. DNS. Komm, eine Library,
die schon DNS heißt. Das kann nicht schlecht sein. So, DNS-Library. 344 Sterne. DNS-Libraries.
Client. Nee, Client brauch ich nicht. Server. DNS-Server, Klaas. Exposes a proxy domain
name server. UDP only. UDP only ist in Ordnung. You can intercept domain name resolu... Okay,
das machen wir jetzt einfach mal. Nee, weiterleiten irgendwohin will ich es nicht. Okay, wir probieren
es jetzt mal aus, Leute. Wir tauschen mal kurz die Fenster. Machen die IDE dahin. Also,
da brauchen wir DNS. DNS. Das da? GitHub? Ist das das Richtige? Shithub? Öffnen, please.
Ja, das hat sich aktualisiert. Captain. DNS. Jawoll, den brauchen wir. Wir copypasten jetzt
einfach das Example. Masterfile gibt es nicht. Add record. Das sollte ziemlich easy werden,
wenn das alles so funktioniert, wie es da steht. Masterfile brauchen wir nicht. Einfach
nur DNS-Server. Ich will ja nichts auflösen. Ich will einfach nur eine IP auflösen. Hoffentlich
geht das. String. Endpoint. Nee. Ich will das ohne... Ich will es nicht weiterleiten.
Ich könnte den DNS weiterleiten irgendwohin, wo es das nicht gibt. Also, kein... Also,
keine Ahnung. 1, 9, 2, 1, 6, 8. Keck.W. Keine Ahnung. 990.99. Gibt es bestimmt nicht.
Ach, okay. Das mit Masterfile braucht man anscheinend. Masterfile. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich
hier mache. Hab ich schon nie ausprobiert. Masterfile. So, Google lösen wir nicht. Wobei,
wir können das einfach mal so testen. Und dann muss man sagen, run-await-server-listen.
Okay. Easy. Easiest. Wetterchamp..net-run. Dick. Ach so. Weil Port 53. Okay. Ist okay.
Google..de. Wow. Monkeys. Guck mal, die Anfragen kommen schon rein, Leute. Die Anfragen...
Eieiei. Die ist ganz schön am Spam. Die Wetterstation. Spamchamp. Aber Google... Ach nee. Google.
.com kann er auflösen. Google..com löst er auf. Okay, das funktioniert schon. Easy.
Leute, das ist ja der einfachste DNS Server der Welt, Alter. So. Loggen. Wollen wir
gar nichts. Wer will schon? Loggen. Loggen ist overrated, outdated, debated. Wir wollen
auflösen. Was wollen wir eigentlich noch mal auflösen? Hat irgendjemand aufgepasst?
DNS. Static. Das wollen wir auflösen. Hool.ntp.org wollen wir auflösen. Und zwar auf 121.288.1.
Und? Und? Wir wollten noch irgendwas auflösen. ECOVID. CD-Dings ECOVID. Und zwar auf
121.278.1.127. Das muss man dann mit statischen IPs vom Raspberry Pi oder so austauschen.
Man könnte sogar noch Get IP from Host. Get... Interface IP from Host. Können wir unten
drunter machen. So. Moment. Das ist falsch rum. Sixhead. Time. Wir lösen jetzt nicht
einfach nur Namen zu IPs auf. Wir lösen IPs auch zu Namen auf. So. Schauen wir mal ob
das funzt. Ja. Funzt. Okay. Und jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Web Server. Ja stimmt. Reverse
DNS. Gibt's ja. Reverse Lookup. Kannste ja machen. Minimal API. Ich hab ne Konsol App
gemacht. Das ist ziemlich doof. Ich hätte Minimal API Web Anwendung machen sollen.
Weil. Weil. Ich brauch nen Web Server. Okay. Leute. Sekunde. Der Wetterchamp muss. Muss
weg. Passt. Wenn du was wissen willst. Sagt Bescheid. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich so wie
in der Schule. Wenn der Lehrer gefragt hat nachdem er null gecheckt hat. Willst du was
wissen. Und dann sagen die Leute immer. Ja was hast du nicht verstanden. Und dann kommt
die Antwort alles. Sie scharfen auf Linux klar. Warum nicht. Mk dir Wetterchamp. Warum
nicht. Ich programmiere dort nicht seit letzten drei Jahren nur so exklusiv unter. Unter
Linux überhaupt kein Problem. Easy. Also du kannst spätestens seit. Net Core ohne Probleme.
Ach so der Wetterchamp heißt dann nicht mehr so. Du kannst spätestens seit. Net Core ohne
Probleme auf Linux entwickeln. Es ist alle mal besser als sich mit Windows rum zu ärgern.
Ich habe. Alles klar. Haben wir hier alle schon für Zeug gemacht. Wo ist denn der Wetterchamp.
So jetzt haben wir eine minimale Web Anwendung. Öffnen please. Mit Rider hier. Das ist Jet
Brains 5 Head Zeug. Du kannst dir die Rider selbst kaufen. Also kannst dir die Testversion
30 Tage angucken. Und es gibt auch Möglichkeiten die Testversion zu resetten. Das will ich
jetzt hier aber nicht näher ausführen. Also ich habe mir von Jet Brains das All Desktop
App gekauft. Das kostet glaube ich 240 Euro im ersten Jahr. 200 im zweiten Jahr und 180
im dritten Jahr oder so. Und da kannst du alle Jet Brains Produkte benutzen. Und ehrlich
gesagt ich finde das lohnt sich. Wenn man das öfters verwendet. So also hier haben wir
unseren DNS Server und hier haben wir unseren Web Server. Das heißt den DNS Server den
verfrachten wir mal den eigenen Thread. Task Run. Das wird ein Miniprogramm. Das wird 20
Zeilen dann ist es fertig. Basic. Ja gut passt. Eigener Thread offen. Jetzt schauen wir mal
ob das funktioniert. Wetterchamp. Dotnet. Run. Sudo weil Port 53. DNS als Hosted Service.
Du hast recht das wäre gar nicht schlecht weil dann würde sich das auch automatisch
stoppen. Dick. Geht. Ja als Hosted Service wäre wahrscheinlich doch nicht schlecht dann
stoppt und start sich das automatisch. So hier haben wir unseren DNS Service. So und
jetzt haben wir hier unsere Web Anwendung. Also was ruft das China Chinesen Ding noch
mal auf. Perl. Hier. AP. Data AP ruft das auf. Und die Antwort muss dann folgendes sein.
Das da. So das probieren wir jetzt aus ob das funktioniert. Übrigens habt ihr schon
gesehen eines der besten Features von C-Sharp 11. C-Sharp. Elf. Oder zwölf. Elf glaube
ich. Raw String Literance. Man kann jetzt endlich. Man kann jetzt endlich so was hier
machen. Ultra High Res Screenshot ich weiß. Man kann jetzt endlich so was machen. Anführungszeichen
Anführungszeichen Anführungszeichen. Oder es kämpft automatisch alles innen drin. Leider
habe ich noch kein C-Sharp 11 weil man ist das. Dort nicht sieben Release Date. Irgendwann
im November ist das meistens. Ja November. Jetzt müssen wir noch so was hier machen.
Machen wir einen Block falls wir noch ein bisschen mehr machen wollen. Sollte mir nicht
Ryder eigentlich vorschlagen wenn ich Copy Paste. Dass ich Copy Paste und Replace. Okay
also das hier antworten wir jetzt. Auf Slash Data AP antworten wir das da. Und wir machen
noch mal einen Log. Wir sind nicht in JavaScript hier. Was weiß ich. Irgendwas dass wir einfach
was sehen. Okay starten. Vision Returns und nicht direkt Result. Könnte ich machen. Aber
ich gehe davon aus ich brauche hier noch ein bisschen mehr Sachen drinne. Später. Weiß
ich ja nicht. Muss ja Abfragen machen. Was ist die Time Zone und Zeug. Curl Local Host.
Der Port stimmt nicht. Muss Port 80 sein. Das ist nicht Port 80. Das ist Port 5173.
Debugger ist Console Log Debugging. Beste. Launch Settings. IES Alter. Komm mal dann dahin.
Lul. Hat irgendjemand die letzten 20 Jahre IES verwendet. Ich lach euch auch nicht aus
Leute interessiert mich nur. Also ich nicht. 80. That's dead. So der Wetterchamp. Lauscht
an Port 53. Port 44042. UDP. Okay warum nicht. Keine Ahnung warum. Und auf 80. Alles klar.
Okay Curl Local Host. Ne anders. Curl. Hä. Hab ich das nicht noch irgendwie. Der Historie.
Keine Ahnung. Okay Curl. 1227. Data. IP. AP war das glaube ich. Ne. Was. Data IP. Ach
der ist auf Local Host 80. Moment. Moment. Ich habe mich vertan. Ich will nicht auf
Local Host. Ich will global lauschen auf 80. Okay. Alles klar. Chat. Ich bin gespannt.
Ich mache noch mal kurz Debug für den DNS an. Dass wir was mitbekommen vom DNS. So.
Und jetzt starte ich das Ding neu. Und. Der sollte sich jetzt beim DNS. Beim DNS den
Name holen von seinem Web Server. Und. Dann die Uhrzeit setzen. Amazon. Alter dieses China
Ding fragt die halbe Welt an. I do. Der muss NTP Update anfragen. Nur dann funktioniert
das geschalt. Amazon. Amazon. Bei du. CDN Update. Eko wird. Ja. Okay.
Jetzt hört er auch auf abzufragen. Okay. Okay. Aber. Aber die Uhrzeit. Geht
was mit der Verbindung nicht. Kann das sein. Ach so. Vielleicht ist er verwirrt. Weil Rain.
Ne. Es kam gar nicht. Okay. Ja das muss weg. Ich weiß gar nicht wo hier was anfängt und
aufhört. Ehrlich gesagt. Mit den ganzen Anführungszeichen. So. Hoffen wir mal.
Warum hat er so viele Anführungszeichen. So reicht doch oder. Funktioniert die Verbindung
vielleicht nicht. Hast du denn den internen NTP schon am Laufen. Ja. Okay Leute es wird
Zeit für Wireshark glaube ich. Ich muss mal. Ich muss mal die Debug Ausgabe etwas reduzieren.
Wisst ihr was wir machen jetzt einfach mega fette Debug Ausgabe. Ich könnte auch ein
Debugger nehmen. So was sollte dann dazwischendrin auftauchen. Warum eigentlich Endserver setzen
weil der Konstraktor das unbedingt haben will. Okay ich glaube ich habe irgendwas in meinen
Firewall Regeln verkackt. Report 80 passt eigentlich. Okay Leute es wird Zeit für eine
Runde Wireshark. Es müsste. Also von der Idee her müsste es eigentlich passen. Sollte das
nicht Euro Berlin sein. Doch. Ist doch. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen geht es nicht. Neustart.
53 Port 80 zu China Chinesen IP. Da sollte aber nicht hin. Er sollte eigentlich probieren
auf Port 80. Auf mein internes zu gehen. Mal kurz schauen was habe ich denn da eingetragen
zum auflösen. Ist doch richtig. Interne IP sollte er DNS auflösen. Eigentlich alles
in Ordnung. Sofern die DNS Auflösung ordentlich funktioniert. China AP Port 80. Ich lasse
es jetzt mal kurz zwei drei Minuten laufen. Nee nee der nimmt nicht sein eigenen. Der nimmt. 60.
Ah ja gut 60.2 ist das falsch. Das ist okay 60.2 schickt er die Wetterdaten hin. Nee nee
das macht das schon richtig. Er geht doch auf Port 80 dahin. Er geht auf Port 80. Das funktioniert
doch. Habt ihr es gesehen. Guck mal da. Alles gut. Macht er noch. Alles alles richtig eigentlich.
Okay. Stopp. Da müssen wir uns mal den Wireshark Dump angucken. Keg W P Cap. Download. Wireshark.
Ein bisschen verkleinern den Krempel. Also. NTP hat schon mal funktioniert. Klient. Response.
Network Time Protokoll. Received. 7. Mai. Ja ja alles gut. Okay. DNS. Wir müssen nach einem
DNS Query gucken für RTP Punkt. Oder wir können einfach RTP gucken. Leute. Das ist ein Get Map
Post. Alter. Das ist ein Post Request. Kein Get Request. Du machst das alles so dass in
dein Smartphone eingebundenes Zeug und die China Chinesen Software runter ist. Nee ja
ich mach das dass ich dieses Ding nicht ins Internet hängen muss. Und vor allem mich interessiert
wie es funktioniert. Ich hab den Post nicht gemapped. Method Not Allowed. Okay. Jetzt.
Okay. Ich weiß woran es liegt. Siehste. Mein Fehler. Habe ich verkehrt gemacht. Curl minus
X Post.
Ich bin auch im falschen Ordner. Ich muss das mal zu machen. Das ist mir zu verwirrend
jetzt. Okay. Ich denke dass ich nochmal neu starten muss. Denke dass ich nochmal neu starten
muss. Packets. Start.
Erkennt man es am besten so. Wann kommt Port 80 Leute. GIF Port 80 Blitz. Und dann brauchen
wir eine Library die uns Sonnenuntergang nach Zeitzone gibt. Kennt ihr da irgendwas. Kennt
ihr. Kennt ihr eine Dotnet Library die mir Sonnenauf und Untergang nach Zeitzone gibt.
Ehrlich gesagt reicht mir. Deutsche Zeitzone. Aber die werden wahrscheinlich alles möglich
können. Kannst du es nicht auch zum Home Assistant holen. Doch. Aber jetzt. Ich schon.
Aber nicht nicht jetzt im Stream. Und außerdem fände ich es unabhängig tatsächlich besser.
Wann geht er denn mal auf Port 80. Geht er heute noch mal auf Port 80. Please. Jetzt.
Bäm. Zeit. Leute. Zeit gesetzt. Poggers. Massive. Ok. Das hier gibt. Das hier sagst
du. Solar Calculator. Aha. Calculates Sunrise and Sunset for a given date and location using
Geocoordinates. Ha. Null. This Library uses the method Outline. No. Ah. Solar Calculations.
Ok. Example. Example. Gibt es da nicht irgendwas anderes. Sunrise Sunset Library. Sunrise
Packages. Das Sunrise zu nennen ist schon ziemlich hängen geblieben, oder? Planet
Rise Time. Ich will es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben. Sunrise Sunset. Fünf Jahre. Null. Wir nehmen
die. Scheint mir ganz aktiv zu sein. Solar Calculator. Ok. Also. Der Solar Calculator.
Bisschen Sündags Highlighting wäre vielleicht auch nicht verkehrt gewesen. Solar. Wie heißt
das Ding? Solar Calculator. NPM Package ist Solar Calculator. So rum. Nicht mit Minus.
So. 3.1. Kommt das hin? Releases. Gibt es nicht. Overrated, Chebaded, Outdated. Gibt
keine Releases. Aber nur Gert Packages. Sagt 3.1. Ok. Das ist der. Ok. So. Return. Wir
starten gar nichts. Wir testen jetzt diese komische Solar Calculator App. Time Zone
Info. Sunrise. Time Zone Convert UTC. Solar Times Sunrise. Wie? Was? Ok. Moment. Ich
copypaste mir das mal kurz. Also. Time Zone Info. Solar Times. Ok. Also. Testen wir das
mal. Time Zone Central Standard Time. Ne. Oh. Ich hasse Day Time Gedöns, Alter. Ok.
Also. Jetzt haben wir Solar Times. Ja. Longitude Latitude für Frankfurt. Suchen wir uns gleich
raus. Convert from UTC. Ich bin verwirrt. Das kann man doch bestimmt schöner machen.
Ok. Sunrise. Google Maps. Also wir brauchen jetzt Längen und Breitenkarten von Frankfurt.
Frankfurt. Ah mein. Die wisst ihr wahrscheinlich nicht auswendig. Und wie bekommt man die?
So bekommt man doch irgendwie raus über. Hier. Da. Da. Guck. Da. Das brauche ich. Das
will ich haben. Das da. Was? Zwölf Komma. Amor. Amor. Amor. Amor. Amor. Amor. Amor.
Komma. Ah Moment. Da habe ich. Ich habe zu viel mit kopiert. So. Ne. Zwölf gehört da
nicht mehr dazu. Ok. Solar Times. Sunset Sunrise. Ok. Dann schauen wir mal. Wir haben Sonnenuntergang
in Frankfurt. PM. MonkaS. Um. 10.51 Uhr. Kann das sein? 22.51 Uhr. Moment. Frankfurt
und Sonnenuntergang. 20.53 Uhr. Das ist einfach weil UTC. Weil UTC Krempel. Wir brauchen
es aber auch in UTC. Wir brauchen es auch in UTC. Guckt mal. ECOVID. Offset. UTC Offset.
Also wir müssen das hier füllen. Sunrise. 22. Ach ne. Ok. Wir brauchen es in lokaler
Zeit. Wir brauchen es in lokaler Zeit. Ok. Das ist. Das ist Pains Champ. Und es ist
auch Central Standard Time. Das ist doch Schwachsinn. Time Zone. Info. Local. Ja. Fertig. Muss doch
reichen. So. Das muss doch reichen hier. Ausführen. Ja. Weil ich es vorher mit Root
gestartet habe. Ja. Was? Moment. Sunrise. Ja. Passt doch. 5.51 Uhr. Ja. Das passt schon.
Ich vertraue eher dieser Library als dem China-Chinesen Zeug. Ok. 5.51 Uhr ist Sunrise und vor allem
warum Date Time Now? Ach für heute. Für heute. Ok. Ja. Das ergibt doch eigentlich
Sinn. Und jetzt das Ganze. Please für. Nicht für Sunrise. Sondern für Sunset. Sunset.
Und jetzt sollte ich auch rausbekommen. Wann die Sonne auf und unter geht. 8 Uhr. Ja. 20.52.
20.52. Kommt hin. Alles klar. So. Und das Ganze jetzt please noch in gescheiter nicht
Freedom Schreibweise. Sondern in 20.42. Date Time Today. 5 hat Alter. Ok. Was kommt
hier eigentlich raus? Sag mal. Das hier ist doch schon ein Date Time. Was macht der da
eigentlich so komische Dinger? Warum kann ich nicht einfach. Sekunde. Warum kann ich
nicht einfach Sunset. Sunrise. Und dann konvertieren in die jeweilige Zeitzone. Warum ist das so
kompliziert? Stimmt doch eigentlich schon oder? So alles gut. Macht er doch schon richtig.
Weil er wahrscheinlich standardmäßig lokal nimmt oder? Wie kriegt man die Time Zone hier
von raus? Gar nicht. Aber das stimmt doch. Ist doch alles richtig. 20.52. Ist eigentlich
alles gut. Die ganze Campbell braucht man doch gar nicht. Ok. Das ist wahrscheinlich
für den Fall der Fälle, dass man. Das braucht man nicht. Das ursprüngliche Beispiel war
ja auch für eine Zeit Zone, die nicht lokal ist. Wenn ich lokal will, dann brauche ich
einfach gar nichts machen. Dann muss ich einfach nur das hier nehmen und fertig ist. Ja Datums
Sachen programmieren. Hör mal auf. So und jetzt. Was für ein Format brauchen wir? 20.52.
Also wir brauchen Short Time T. Und das da. To String T. So mal gucken was da jetzt raus
kommt. Und. Das ist weil er denkt, ich habe ein englisches Setting. Da muss ich doch von
Hand formatieren. Ich brauche HMM. Brauche ich das? Ist das so? HMM. Ja. Ich brauche
HMM. Ja, wenn man die Culture reinhaut, das müsste wahrscheinlich funktionieren. Wenn
man sagt. Kann man überhaupt lokal angeben? Culture Info? Ja. Moment, wer kann das doch
so machen? Culture Info? Ach, scheiß drauf. So ist besser. Okay, geht auch. Okay, nice.
Jetzt haben wir 20.52. Das heißt, das können wir da jetzt einfach reinschreiben. Easy.
Das ist doch. Guck mal, das ist doch eigentlich dann total einfach. So, zack. Weg hier. DNS
läuft wieder. Und hier drin. Machen wir das jetzt einfach so. War Sunrise gleich. Zack.
War Sunset. Oh, falsch rum. Falsch rum. Ihr seht, ihr braucht kein Mindestverhältnis
copypasten. Okay, das heißt, wir müssen das jetzt da folgendermaßen. UTC Offset ist
immer das gleiche, oder? Ach, Moment, ich muss ja auch noch rausbekommen, ob wir gerade
Sommer- oder Winterzeit haben. Morgen, KS. Alter, ich hasse Datumszeit-Krempel. Es leckt
critical information. Aber jetzt schreiben wir erst mal Sunset und sowas. Date Sunrise.
Kann man da Template Strings? Oh, fuck. Wie praktisch werden jetzt String Literals, oder?
Jetzt muss ich es escaping, oder? Fuck, Alter, wie ich das hasse, man. Wie ich das hasse.
Nee, Moment. Moment, ich weiß, woran das liegt. Weil, weil ich kann jetzt ja, ich kann jetzt
ja keine... Ich muss die Klammern escaping, oder? Ich muss die Klammern escaping. Ich
muss jetzt so machen. Richtig? Ah ja, okay. Okay, Klammer Escape stellt. Alles klar. Daytime
ist Daylight Saving Time. Sehr schön. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Ist, haha. Gibt's nicht. Now
is Daylight Saving Time. Macht doch schnell ne Klasse. Komm mal mit. So, also Sunset. Sunset.
Ich bin richtig froh, wenn es dann mal den nächsten C-Sharp-Version die String Literals
kippt. Das ist richtig pock. Vor allem, weil du einstellen kannst. Das kann ich, das zeige
ich euch mal ganz schnell. Sunrise. Du kannst, ich hab elf String Literals. Man kann, was
die uns mit diesem Beispiel sagen wollen. Also String Literals machst du dann mit Double
Quote, Double Quote, Double Quote. Aber das kann man beliebig nesten. Zum Beispiel, wenn
ich ihm sage, wenn ich ihm sage Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen. Was für ein Dollar-Dollar,
nicht Fragezeichen, man. Wenn ich ihm sage Dollar-Dollar, dann bedeutet das, um Template
Strings zu verwenden, ist der Escaper, also das Escape, Geschweifte Klammer ist genauso
viel hintereinander wie die Dollar-Zeichen. Also wenn ich jetzt Dollar-Dollar-Dollar machen
würde, dann müsste ich Geschweifte Klammer auf, Geschweifte Klammer auf, Geschweifte
Klammer auf machen. Das ist ganz praktisch, dass Jason gedönst nicht automatisch den
die Templates escapt. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich glaube man kann sogar die Anzahl
der Quotes variieren. Also ich könnte quasi auch sowas machen wie Dollar-Dollar-Dollar,
Quote-Quote-Quote-Quote-Quote-Quote, so dass es sich am wenigsten beißt mit dem String
drinne. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich Sixhead gemacht, aber vielleicht erstmal nicht so
intuitiv. So, is Daylight Saving Time? Was machen wir jetzt hier? Is Daylight Saving Time?
Moment, das ist ein Bool. Moment, das ist eklig. Zick, Sekunde. DST gleich. Nee, wenn
ich ein Bool...warte mal. Nee, Bool to String geht nicht. Ich mein, so kann man...gibt's
da was schöneres, Leute? Gibt's da was schöneres? Convert oder so? Convert to...nee, da wird's
nix, da wird's nie...to Int? Gibt's sowas? Nee. Also wenn einem was schöneres einfällt,
dann immer her damit. So, jetzt haben wir das. Time Zone is Berlin, Europe Berlin, UTC Offset.
Moment Leute, was ist denn...was ist denn das für ein UTC Offset? 7200? Was ist denn
das? Minuten? Nee, kann ja nicht sein. Durch 60? Ah, Minuten, das sind Minuten. 120 Minuten.
Nee, das sind Minuten. 120...also in Sekunden. Jaja, 120 Minuten in Sekunden. So rum. Ja,
meine Güte. 120 Minuten Sekunden. Wie krieg ich den UTC Offset raus? Ich mein, wir können
die aller...die aller...die billigste Variante überhaupt machen. Die billigste Variante
wär so. So. Und der Offset ist quasi wenn...haben wir schon Sommerzeit, Leute? Hab...haben wir
gerade schon Sommerzeit? Ja? Okay. Und dann ansonsten die Hälfte. Was ist denn das? Durch
2? Null. Gut. So. Also ich mein, das wär...das ist nicht so schön. Wir können jetzt übrigens
was Neues...was Neues verwenden. Bloß als Convert to Int, dein Bull. Hoa. Hi, Fedder.
Convert...ich dachte mir, dass irgendwas mit Convert geht, aber...2 Int, ja, das sollte
reichen. Wahrscheinlich 2 Byte, oder? Gibt es...2 Bit? 2 Bit? Nee. 2 Byte sollte ja eigentlich
reichen, oder? Kommt da jetzt das Richtige raus? Werden wir gleich sehen. Werden wir jetzt
gleich sehen. Testen wir. Sehen wir...sehen wir gleich, ob das Richtige rauskommt. Okay.
Ähm. Nicht Return. Was mach ich denn hier? Switch können wir doch machen. Wie macht
man das jetzt gescheit? Okay. Offset? Offset? Gleich. Moment. Moment. Ich benutze Switch
Expressions relativ selten. Obbei, ich brauch keine Switch Expression. Jetzt...jetzt...jetzt
aber so, Leute. Jetzt aber so. Ich mein, schön wär's natürlich, wenn man das unabhängig
von der Zeit...C Sharp. Offset UTC. Da gibt's doch bestimmt was eingebautes. Get UTC. Okay.
Easy. Get UTC. Offset. Get UTC. Achso. Time Zone. Info. Get...nee. Was ist es denn?
Time Zone. Äh. Oder muss ich Date Time Now? Äh. Nee, dann weiß ich's nicht. Get
Time Zone. Info. Und dann UTC. Offset. Ah. Sowas hier. Ja, aber nur Time Zone ist Deprecated.
Das will ich nicht. Time Zone Info. Wie verwendet man den Krempel? Ach, Local. Local. UTC.
Offset. Time Span. Ja, okay. Noch viel besser. Ähm. Und das Ganze jetzt in Sekunden. Okay,
jetzt...jetzt checken wir mal, ob das sinnvoll ist. Was ich da...was ich da mache. Also,
warten wir's mal. Ja. Mal schauen. Local Hosts. Was? Local Hosts. Nee, 1, 2, 7. Null und eins.
Wait. Was? Eins? Äh. Eins? Also eins ist okay. Eins ist in Ordnung. Eins ist der...eins
ist DST. Aber. Was ist der Offset? Warum ist der Offset so ppeger? Local. Es müssten
doch eigentlich. Äh. Weiß der überhaupt, was ich für eine lokale Zeit hab? Central
Europe Time. Berlin. UTC plus eins. Ich dachte, wir haben UTC plus zwei. Haben wir UTC plus
eins oder UTC plus zwei? Ah, zwei Zonen. Scheiße, Alter. Nee, im Winter ist es plus
zwei, oder? Nee, wir haben plus. Ich bleck da mal. Das ist ppeger Kram. Was? Da steht
doch 27. Wo? Wo steht 27? Das ist die hardcoded Antwort, die immer kommt. So Leute, ich hab
da keinen Bock drauf. Wir machen so, wie ich's vorher gemacht hab. Offset. Das kann man
schöner machen, aber so funktioniert's auf jeden Fall. 7200, alles gut. Offset. Offset.
Okay, wir haben's. Nice. So. Wir haben's geschafft. Das heißt, wir kamen jetzt komplett ohne
China-Chinesen-Api. Kriegen wir jetzt unsere Wetterstation eingestellt. Darfst du fragen,
was das Ziel ist? Ja, ich zeig's dir. Kannst du gucken. Kannst du gucken. Also, ich hab
hier eine Wetterstation. Die möchte, also so die Konsole für die Wetterstation, die
Wetterstation ist draußen. Die möchte zu einem China-Server sich verbinden. Und wir
haben jetzt das, was der China-Server macht, versucht nachzubauen. Das heißt, was diese
Konsole jetzt macht, ist, die versucht per NTP ihre Zeit abzurufen. Da biegen wir mit
einem DNS poolntp.org um, auf den lokalen NTP. NTP-Request funktionieren. Und dann biegen
wir die China-Chinesen-Staatsseite um auf den lokalen Web-Server. Und der lokale Web-Server
antwortet das hier. Und jetzt sollte sich nach 1-2 Minuten, guck mal, bei du Amazon
com, was die für Abfragen macht, und jetzt sollte sich nach ein paar Minuten das Ding
automatisch auf die Uhrzeit einstellen. Und irgendwann sollte das jetzt eigentlich funktionieren.
Jawoll. Bam. Easy. Clap, Leute. Easy. Easy. Clap. Easy. Kann man dazu, kann man nur sagen.
Seht ihr mal, was das Ding für Anfragen heraushämmert, oder? Bei du und sonst was. Und wir wissen
ja noch nicht mal, was das normalerweise sonst so schicken würde. Das macht ja noch zig
andere. Das macht ja auch noch, versucht ja noch, TCP-Verbindungen zu machen. Das macht
UDP, Broadcast. Das macht vor allem, gut, die kommen nicht aus dem Netz raus. Das macht
vor allem noch weitere TCP-Verbindungen, versucht es aufzumachen, nach China. Port 2525, wir
wollen irgendwelche Mails verschicken oder so. Es funktioniert. Okay, eine Sache, just for
fun, die wir noch machen könnten. Gibt es ein.NET NTP-Server? Dann kann das nämlich
alles, alles, was man braucht in diesem einen Programm dann. Gibt es ein NTP-Server? Yacht.
Durillia NTP. NTP-Client. From NTP. Das vielleicht. Network-Clock. NTP-Server, okay. Vielleicht
soll ich mal nach NTP-Server suchen. Geil, ich suche noch NTP-Server und finde erst mal
NTP-Client. CaveNet. NTP-Client-Server, aha, aha. Cave.net, noch nie gehört, im Leben
nicht. Okay, also was haben wir hier zu bieten? Britt. Sekunde. Britte. Britte. Brille. Brilleite.
Web4b. Nullstars. Ich glaube, das wollen wir nicht verwenden. Health-Checks-NTP. Nee,
das ist ein Health-Check. Das ist ein Health-Check für einen NTP-Server. Das ist kein NTP-Server.
China-Chinesen-Zeug. Nee, nee. Cave.net. Ein, ein Sterben. Perfekt. Das, das ist ja
vertrauenserweckend, Alter. Ich bin mir ja nicht so sicher, ob ich das verwenden will.
NTP-Server. CS. Das ist übersichtlich, oder? Das ist gar nicht so, gar nicht so. Okay,
wir suchen jetzt einfach mal ein NTP-Server. NTP-Server. Und dann gucken wir mal. Wir sind
drin, Chat. Wir sind drin in GitHub. Go. Go-Web-Server. Go-Server bringt mir jetzt nichts. Ah, jetzt
geht es hier auch wieder. DDoS attacks using NTP-Server. Ich glaube, das will ich jetzt
hier im Stream nicht machen. NTP-Micro-Server. Tiny-CLR-OS. Was? Quick-and-Dirty-NTP-Server.
Perfekt. Open-SNTP-Server. Simple open source implementation of SNMTP-Protocol. Auch okay.
Gebt mir den NTP-Server für.NET. DZNTP klingt auch sehr vertrauenswürdig. Also, ich habe
schon vielfältigere Libraries gesehen als das, was man hier gerade bei NTP-Servern findet.
Das ist doch ein bisschen wüsstlich. Pains-Champ. Quick-and-Dirty. Zwölf Jahre. What the fuck?
Zwölf Jahre. Und das ist irgendein Background-Windows-Crap. Okay, Leute. Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige,
was ich Sinnvolles gefunden habe hier. Vielleicht sollte ich mal nach SNTP C-Sharp suchen. Server-Library.
Google. Nicht S-M-T-P. S-N-T-P. Client. Client. Alles Clients. Ich brauche den gar nicht. Ich
kann ohne Probleme den NTP vom Router verwenden. Ich wollte einfach nur wissen, ob es sowas gibt.
Eher just for fun. Nicht, weil ich das wirklich brauche. Es gibt aber auch nichts Gescheites.
Das macht niemand von Hand. Ja, das ist echt das Einzige, was ich gefunden habe. Und das
gibt es nicht als Nougat. W32TM. Nein, nein, nein. Warum das Rad neu erfinden? Weil es geht.
Das will ich nicht. Nein, nein. Das bleibt so, wie es ist jetzt. Ich brauche keinen NTP-Server.
Ich nehme den von meinem Router. Das ist kompletter Schwachsinn. Warum sollte ich den hier nehmen?
Er gibt keinen Sinn. Okay, Leute. Wir haben das hinbekommen. Guck mal. Funktioniert relativ gut.
Ich meine, die Wettervorhersage. Ich brauche keinen NTP im Docker. Ich habe NTP-Server
an allen Ecken laufen. Also gut, das stimmt gar nicht. Ich habe den NTP-Server auf meinem
Router laufen. Das reicht. Das Einzige ist, ich glaube, die Wettervorhersage. Die funktioniert
nicht. Die kann aber auch gar nicht funktionieren, weil die Wettervorhersage holt sich garantiert aus
China von irgendeinem China-Chinesen-Server. Und die Station hat auch eine App bzw. Wie hast
du geplant, die Daten in Home Assistant zu packen? Ganz einfach. Mit der offiziellen
ECOVID-Integration. Die Wetterstation schickt das an den Server alle paar Minuten. Das funktioniert.
Das habe ich mir schon mal angeguckt. Mir ging es eher darum, wie man an diese Station rankommt.
Ja, und die Wettervorhersagen, ganz ehrlich, die ist mir egal. Juckt mich nicht. Da müsste
man sich jetzt halt noch anschauen, was das noch für Web-Requests macht. Ich meine, das Ding,
das China-Chinesen-Ding hier, guckt mal, das fragt ziemlich oft auf Port 80, irgendeine
China-Seite an. Stopp. Stopp, ich kopiere mir das noch mal runter. Download. Ich mache noch
mal Wireshark auf. Wireshark. So, und jetzt schauen wir mal. Port 80. Guck, das versucht
hier zu dieser China-Chinesen-Seite zu kommen. 4710223. Wollen wir mal gucken, was da passiert,
wenn ich da einen Curl hinschicke? Wie wäre jetzt die Amazon-DNS-Requenz abgefährdet? Gar nicht.
Da gibt es einfach keine Antwort drauf. Was ist denn da dahinter? Who is 47. Aber das hatten wir
schon geguckt vorhin, oder? Das hatten wir vorhin schon geguckt. Das war Aliexpress-Cloud, Alibaba-Cloud.
Nee, Cody Kneiter war was anderes. Oder? Nee, Cody Kneiter war die... Nochmal Cody Kneiter,
weil hier kommt das Gleiche. Also wenn ich das rausbekommen will, ich müsste jetzt die IP
weiterleiten irgendwie. Was ist das hier? Data oder AP? AP? Page not found. Nee, was war das?
AP data. Data not found. Ich müsste die IP auf NetCant weiterleiten wieder und dann müssten wir
schauen, wie leite ich denn die IP weiter? Mit einem Nut, oder? Funktioniert das? Okay,
Sekunde. NetCant. Port ausmachen. Port 80 bringt mir ja nichts. Ich muss diese IP weiterleiten,
hier. Die Chinesen-IP. Die da, hier. Ah, so viele Anfragen. Monkeys? Der pingt? ICMP? Ach nee,
das sind ICMP-Fehlermeldungen wahrscheinlich. Ja, Amazon. Wo ist die China-IP? Die brauchen wir
jetzt. Copy value. Okay, wir müssen jetzt... Wie mache ich das jetzt gescheit? Nut? Okay, Nut.
Source-IP 192.88.251. Die anderen DNS-Requests mit Null beantworten. Nee, ich muss die IP weiterleiten.
Ich muss die IP umleiten von... Oder kann ich nicht irgendeinen Routing-Eintrag oder so machen?
Ich muss die IP umleiten, wo dahin connecten will. Okay. Source-Address. Destination-Address.
Ist die da? Source-Extras. Advanced. Nee, Action. Action-Destination-Nut. To-Adress. 122.161.27. Boah,
ob das funktioniert, was ich hier umschreibe. Da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt. Port 80.
Ihr Destination-Port. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es Port 80 ist. Boah, fuck. Keine Ahnung.
Kann ich irgendwie IPs umleiten? Okay, Apply. Was? Oh, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Das hat mich irgendwie verklickt. Okay. Ob das funktioniert? MonkaS, Alter. Das klappt doch
im Leben nicht, diese Weiterleitung von der IP, oder? Source-Duster-Destination-Weitergeleitet.
Jetzt auf meine. Das klappt doch im Leben nicht. Und ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob es Port 80 ist
überhaupt. Okay, Packets. Das sehen wir relativ schnell, Leute. Stop, Start. Das sehen wir
relativ schnell. Okay, es hat nicht funktioniert. Es hat nicht funktioniert, sonst wäre hier was
reingekommen. Der macht noch nicht mal den Handshake. Das funktioniert nicht. Moment,
Port 80. Ach so, ja doch. Port 80 muss ich weiterleiten. Protocol-TCP-Port-80-Apply.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das so umschreiben kann überhaupt, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich habe
legit keinen Blasenschimmer. Und ob Firewall-Technik funktioniert überhaupt? Keine Ahnung. Wow,
was macht er denn jetzt? Was zum? Er broadcastet wie verrückt. Was macht er denn jetzt? Alter,
das Schieter-Ding. Was macht es denn? Ich bin jetzt wirklich ein bisschen planlos,
wie ich da die IP ordentlich umleiten würde. Okay, wir machen noch mal kurz. Also, ich sage
nicht, ob wir das so umschreiben. Sollte ich das vielleicht da oben hin machen auf Null? Sicher ist
sicher. Stopp. Bei meinem Netcat steht U, das ist falsch. Ich brauche einen TCP-Listen. Manchmal
sehe ich die Dinge einfach nicht. So, Stopp-Start. Und jetzt ziehen wir einen Stecker raus und machen
wieder rein. Okay, jetzt warten wir, bis er auf die China-Chinesen-Seite zugreift. Ja, TCP-IP-80.
Hey, nee. Moment, ist das das Gleiche? Ist das einfach die Ecovids-Seite?
Löst das vielleicht dahin auf? Äh, nicht wirklich. Was? Stopp. Porta,
80. Ja, der hat... Das ist eine IP, Public-IP für dieses Ecovids-Zeug. Das ist die Default-IP
von dem Wetterservice. Die ist da anscheinend hardcoded drin, weil der hat bisher nur Port 80
an diese China-IP geschickt. Der hat gar nicht versucht, das an mich zu schicken direkt. Das
ist der Request, den habe ich gekriegt. Das ist die Default-IP von diesem China-Ding.
Also, das wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, weil mein Host falsch ist.
Telnet? Okay, Hacker-Man-Time, Leute. Wo ist die IP? Ah, wo habe ich die IP noch mal hingeschrieben?
Da. Telnet, Port 80. So, wir müssen jetzt HTTP von Hand machen, Leute. Nee, wir müssen
Postrequest von Hand machen. Oh Gott. Wobei, nee, wir müssen kein Postrequest von Hand machen.
Wir müssen... Wir nehmen Postman und machen den Request. Wo komme ich denn da überhaupt raus?
Cody Kneider. Wie ging das nochmal? Host? Ach, keine Ahnung. Moment. Telnet-ATTP-Request.
Mit Host. Ach, zuerst den GET-Request. Erst den GET-Request. Okay. Also, GET. Oh, fuck,
jetzt kann man das machen. Okay, scheiß drauf. GET-Host. Host. Page not found. Das ist das Ding.
Das ist die China-API. Ja, mit SSL, aber ist ja ohne SSL. Das ist die China-API. Data-API.
Ja. Das ist die China-API. Also, GET slash API HTTP slash 1.0. Das ist, weiß ich nicht,
ob man beim zweiten Host auch so angeben kann. CD. Das ist die China-API. Das ist die default
IP von der China-API. Okay, jetzt haben wir auch geklärt, was der Standard-Request ist.
So, was mir da natürlich immer noch nicht genau sagt, woher die Wetterstation angebliche
Wettervorhersage bekommt. Da gucken wir mal ins Handbuch rein, was die denn überhaupt sagen,
was dieses Display bedeutet. Nicht Datasheet. Okay, das ist es manuell. Amazon, Baidu vielleicht,
ja. Leute, soll ich nochmal DNS-technisch faken, dass ich Amazon und Baidu auflösen kann?
Ja, okay. Also, wir gucken uns mal kurz das Display an, ob das überhaupt eine Wettervorhersage
ist. Nicht mal beschrieben, was das ist, oder? Ja, vier. Doch, Wettervorhersage. Oder errechnet
er die Wettervorhersage irgendwie selbst? Ich glaube, das macht der Lokal. Das ist überhaupt
nicht von irgendeinem API-Teil. Aber wir lösen trotzdem mal Amazon auf. Mich interessiert
nämlich einfach, was der macht. Wir lösen trotzdem mal Amazon auf. Also, DNS-Server.
Amazon.com. Was hatten wir noch in Baidu? War das auch Baidu.com? Habt ihr euch das
gemerkt? Baidu.com oder Baidu.com? Map. Map. Get. Slash. Ups. Komm mal.
Äh, konnte man ja nicht irgendwie den Body-Readen oder so da drin? HTTP-Kontext. Body? Nee,
ja. Raw HTTP-Request, Alter. HTTP-Request. Body. Read. Äh, wie hat man das nochmal gelesen?
Nee, nee, der Pfad muss Slash sein. Achso, ja gut, je nachdem. Ich weiß nicht, was die
fragen. Ist auch egal. Hauptsache Return-Keg-W. Wie? So, perfekt. Run. Wir schneiden das einfach
wieder mit. Wir schneiden das einfach wieder mit und gucken uns dann, gucken uns das Ganze
an im Dump. Da sieht man das besser. Start. Packages. Bip. Bip, bip. Das lassen wir mal
kurz laufen. Geht da wieder auf die China-Seite, Alter. Guckt mal, Leute. Seht ihr? Das ging
instant. Das ging... Leute, noch viel besser. Anstatt das RTP-Update umzuleiten. Ich leite
einfach diese IP. Wobei, das musst du dann wieder auf dem Access-Point machen. Baidu
mal für die Sub-Domain. Okay. Schauen wir mal, das sollte es hier eigentlich anzeigen.
Amazon. W ist es auch www.amazon.com, die ihr fragt. Guckt. Was will der Dude von Amazon?
Das frage ich mich jetzt wirklich. Kann man auch Sub-Domain hinzufügen? New Domain. Kann
man da auch Sub-Domains machen. Ich weiß nicht eben, das ist halt die Sache, ob es mit Sternchen
geht. Keine Ahnung. Also Amazon fragt er ab baidu.com. Okay. Nochmal kurz neu starten. Amazon.com.
Jawoll. Hat er aufgelöst jetzt? Gut. Und jetzt hat er auch Baidu. Er hat nur Baidu.
Hat Amazon. Doch, Amazon hat er auch gemacht. Okay. Dann können wir den Dump eigentlich
ausmachen. Wir können mal kurz gucken, was er macht. Also hat Baidu aufgelöst und jetzt
versucht er irgendwie darauf zuzugreifen? Nö. Warum auch immer der Amazon auflöst?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Job. CD. Wireshark. Moment, habe ich downloadet? Habe ich downloadet?
Nee, habe ich nicht. Download. Naja. Wireshark. Also UDP, der macht API, mein Request hier.
So und dann löst er Amazon auf. Wir gucken mal kurz von unten. Guck mal, das ist schon
Amazon. Amazon antwortet ihm auch. Also. Dann macht er ein Ping. Moment. Ping der Amazon
und Baidu, um zu checken, ob das Internet ab ist. Checkt er, ob der online ist? Baidu
und Amazon, weil der denkt sich Baidu und Amazon ist nie gleichzeitig offline. Ist das
ein China-Chinesen-Internet-Check? Was auch immer. Boah, Alter. China-Kram. Ok, gut.
China-Chinesen-Krempel. Alles klar. Ok, aber das ist praktisch. Dieses. Dieses
Dornett-Programm, was wir hier gebastelt haben. Eine Sache mache ich jetzt noch schnell. Obwohl
weiß ich denn, war ich das heute noch? Ich bin doch jeder Einzige, der den Krempel benutzt.
Ich muss das nicht generic machen. Ich habe nämlich gesagt, ich suche mir noch die Zeitzone
dynamisch raus und sowas. Da könnten das theoretisch auch andere Leute benutzen, aber
außer mir wird das eh niemand verwenden. Warum sollte ich das überhaupt anpassen? Ja,
weil man könnte natürlich noch sagen, so was wie Timezone-Info und dann irgendwie Name
oder sowas. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich Euro-Berlin aus diesen Timezone-Infos überhaupt raus
bekomme. Das lasse ich so. Alles gut. Das bleibt so. Also, China-Chinesen-Ding funktioniert.
Sie sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen der Meinung, der Mond ist da? Ach nee, das ist Mondphase
oder sowas. Meine Güte. Was für China-Kram wieder. Okay Leute, reicht für heute. Heute
ist Halbmond. Wieso blinkt das da oben noch? Wahrscheinlich, weil es Daten per WLAN übermittelt,
vermute ich mal. Alter Leute, das übertreibt es mal nicht. Der Chat, voll am Durchdrehen
hier. Guck mal, die Emotes gehen gar nicht, weil ich noch nicht reloaded habe. Der Chat,
guckt zu euch an. Wie kommuniziert denn die Station mit den Apps über WLAN? Die Apps
sind richtig mies, total beschissen. Nee, nee, direkt. Oder über eine Cloud, das geht
auch. So, wir haben es geschafft Leute. Also, schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Wir sehen
uns im nächsten Stream. Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen. Bis dann, machts gut. See you.